[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous ravis de vous
retrouver pour notre rendez vous du
mercredi les questions au gouvernement
elle commence dans une rac 1 0 les
sénateurs vont interpeller l'exécutif et
on va en attendant débattre de
l'actualité vous faire vivre cette
séance avec nos journalistes et avec
cette semaine quand un calme et dans
l'hémicycle du sénat
d'où vous allez nous analysé quentin
tous les échangeurs sur quel thème les
sénateurs vont t'ils interroger le
gouvernement cet après-midi et bien
l'émotion ne retombe pas après la mort
du brigadier maçon à avignon et au
lendemain de l'hommage national on
entendra deux questions de sénateurs qui
étaient présents dans la cour et la
préfecture du vaucluse sur donc un seul
cette question des forces de l'ordre
deux autres thèmes majeurs aujourd'hui
on va parler des féminicides après le
drame de mérignac et enfin une question
sur la situation très instable à
jérusalem est
et oui l'actualité intérieures et
internationales et riche effectivement
avec nous également alexandre pouchard
salle des conférences alors qu'ils
allaient vous interviewez cet après midi
à votre micro un bonjour tam et bien je
serai avec le président de la commission
des affaires étrangères du sénat
christian cambon pour évoquer les
escalades de violence actuellement à
jérusalem et dans la bande de gaza merci
alexandre à tout à l'heure et enfin jean
massiet notre streamer politique on a le
plaisir de retrouver comme chaque
mercredi pour voir toutes les réactions
des internautes sur twitter
et oui tu aimes tu t'en doutes en plein
imbroglio sur le pass sanitaire hier à
l'assemblée on a hâte de voir ce qu'en
disent les sénateurs oui on va
d'ailleurs en parler sur ce plateau
également du pass annie terre mais dans
une demi-heure notre face à face la
sénatrice les républicains des bouches
du rhône valérie boyer
elle s'opposera aux sénateurs de la
majorité présidentielle xavier iacovelli
quand on en parlait à l'instant on va
parler ensemble de sécurité alors que
deux policiers ont été tués en douze
jours comment répondre au malaise des
forces de l'ordre comment endiguer la
violence dans les quartiers assistons
nous à une crise de l'autorité de l'état
on en débat à 14h30
[Musique]
mais d'abord le déconfinement dans tous
les esprits alors que les terrasses et
les lieux de culture doivent rouvrir au
public le 19 mai on va s'intéresser au
plan du gouvernement la sortie je cite
jean castex progressive et raisonnée qui
doit nous permettre de voir le bout du
tunnel
la méthode du gouvernement était la
bonne est-ce trop tôt qu'elle garde fous
mettre en place quatre invité pour
tenter de répondre à toutes ces
questions quatre invités tous médecins
avec nos bernard jomier bonjour bonjour
vous êtes sénateur écologiste sujet ici
au groupe socialiste de paris vous avez
été notamment co rapporteur de la
commission d' enquête sur le comité est
également présidé la mission
d'information sur les effets du
confinement avec nos également florence
lassarade bonjour vous êtes sénatrice
les républicains de la gironde et vous
avez notamment écrit qu écrit un rapport
sur les vaccins dans le cadre des
travaux de l'opecst office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologiques avec nous également
sébastien mirek vous êtes médecin
anesthésiste réanimateur au chu de dijon
bonjour je précise aussi que vous
arrêtez référent en marche en côte d'or
et enfin pour compléter ce plateau ce
débat nous sommes avec jean-pierre
thierry vous êtes médecin spécialisé en
santé publique bonjour conseiller
médical à france aso santé d'abord on va
se projeter vers le déconfinement
annoncé et toutes les questions qu'ils
posent parmi les dispositifs prévus par
le gouvernement
le pass sanitaires notamment fait débat
rejeté hier dans un premier temps à
l'assemblée il a finalement été adoptée
à l'issue d'un 2e
vote et certains sénateurs ils sont
également hostiles pierre-henri
holderbaum coup de théâtre hier à
l'assemblée nationale
auteur de cintres est exprimée dessange
aux rites et 106 % 3 contre 108
le projet de loi de la sortie
progressive de l'état d'urgence et le
pass sanitaire n'est pas adoptée par les
députés en raison de la fronde du modem
qui lâche la majorité demandent des
conditions le gouvernement cède il
avance la fin de la période transitoire
au 30 septembre le projet de loi est
finalement adopté dans la nuit pour 208
contre 85 l'assemblée a adopté l'article
concernant le pass sanitaire n'a pas été
modifié pourtant il pose des
interrogations réservé d'abord aux
voyages vers et depuis l'étranger il
sera uniquement utilisé pour les grands
rassemblements de 1000 personnes
comme l'expliquent le ministre de la
santé vous savez mon opposition principe
à l'usagé d'un pass sanitaire pour des
activités de la vie courante tels que
mange au restaurant
en revanche pour les lieux qui concentre
une forte population un fort brassage là
le pass anitea prend son sens le
sénateur loïc hervé et membre de la cnil
émet des réserves sur son utilisation au
premier est une question de principe
comme l'application tous sentis coville
me pose la question de cette idée
finalement qu'on aura pour la première
fois de demander aux personnes de faire
état de leur état de santé
la deuxième c'est le reste
généralisation
si demain il ya un mutant invariants une
quatrième vague
du de l'aco vide ou alors un nouvel
événement sanitaire qui dit que le
général les ont pas d acte encore plus
quotidiens aller au restaurant aller au
cinéma et au théâtre
le projet de loi est attendu au sénat et
sera examiné le 18 mai prochain
alors on va parler un largement du pass
sanitaires sur ce plateau mais d'abord
un mot sur le 19 belle la date qui a été
retenue pour la réouverture
olivier ferrand a fait valoir que
l'épidémie est en décroissance on est
passé ce sont les chiffres qui est la
cité d'une moyenne de 40 mille cas à
18000 cas par jour on est tombé en
dessous des 5000 personnes en
réanimation bernard jomier est ce que
pour vous ces chiffres sont bons et est
ce qu'il montre qu'on a raison de
commencer à des confiner le 19 mai la
semaine prochaine ces chiffres montrent
que l'on a passé le pic de la troisième
vague donc on est en décroissance la
question c'est jusqu'où ça va décroître
est-ce qu'on va avoir une décroissance
qui va s'interrompre et garder un niveau
de circulation du virus moyen voire
élevé surtout si on rouvre est ce que ça
peut leur donner ce qu'on va vraiment
avoir une décroissance plus basse il ya
une cohérence dans les mesures du
gouvernement et une cohérence dans ce
calendrier savoir si c'est la bonne
cohérence la cohérence qui a choisi le
gouvernement c'est à partir du moment où
le risque de saturation totale des
hôpitaux notre service de soins
s'estompe ouvre et donc la montée des
vaccinations de la campagne de
vaccination fait que ce risque s'éloigne
même s'il reste une circulation
relativement élevé virus après est-ce
que accepter une circulation élevé de
virus quand même avec des personnes qui
feront déco vie de long qui feront des
complications et c est ce que c'est une
bonne chose ou est ce qu'il faut aller
vers une série qu'une stratégie autres
de circulation minimal de virus
c'est ça la vraie question voilà c'est
c'est là où la cohérence
on n'est pas sûr qu'elle soit juste
beaucoup de questions effectivement est
ce que pour vous c'est risqué ou est ce
que cela montre que la stratégie du
gouvernement fonctionne florence
lassarade moi je pense qu'il est
souhaitable qu'on se dé confine pas ce
qu'on voit quand même
gaz ou de ces confinement à répétition
le dernier avait été un peu tardif par
rapport à la montée de l'épidémie qu'on
pressentait
et comme comme bernard jomier je pense
que l'adhésion au vaccin et le fait de
pouvoir disposer du lac ça va permettre
de de circonscrire à l'imiter mais par
contre moi ce qui me ce qui me rend
perplexe à chaque fois c'est le grand
désordre et les grandes annonces
contre-annonces petit coup de théâtre à
l'assemblée nationale où et ça c'est des
histoires en fait ces parlementaires
ça veut dire ça y est on va en parler
néanmoins tout se fait dans le plus
grand désordre et au dernier moment il
n'ya pas d'anticipation on parlait des
autotests hier avec les opex lorsque le
gouvernement commande des hôtes opex des
autotests c'est immédiat la livraison
doit être immédiate on prend on pense
pas aux industriels à ce qu'ils ont déjà
promis à l'étranger à l'extérieur ou aux
pharmaciens par exemple donc tout se
fait dans le plus grand désordre moi
c'est ça qui me qui me choque
il ya aussi un petit décalage entre ce
que dit le gouvernement est ce que dit
aujourd'hui le conseiller scientifique
le conseil scientifique la semaine
dernière s'est autosaisie dans son
rapport et bien il s'inquiète un jeu le
site du décalage entre les conditions
d'ouverture envisagé et le niveau de
vaccination de la population qui sera
atteint et également il met en garde je
le cite encore le relâchement des
mesures de restriction ne doit pas être
considérée comme un signal de
relâchement général je pense que tout le
monde est d'accord
jean-pierre thierry vous qui êtes
d'ailleurs dans un centre de vaccination
je crois à meudon
qu'est ce que vous dites vous dites
aussi attention signal il ne faut pas
relâcher les efforts car on peut très
vite retourner en arrière voir les
contaminations s'envoler alors oui parce
que tant qu'on n'est pas un niveau
suffisant de vaccination qui se
rapproche de la cible d' immunité
collective
on a toujours un risque de rebond alors
en même temps s'ils voulaient s'appelle
du stop and go mais on pourrait appeler
ça ouverture fermeture
on sait qu'on peut pas fermer une
société très longtemps donc de temps en
temps le thé obligé de réouvrir donc là
le pari que fait le gouvernement c'est
de ne pas avoir à refermer
jusqu'à ce qu'on arrive à un niveau
d'immunisation par les vaccins suffisant
et donc ça va dépendre de beaucoup de
variables on sera aidé par l'été
évidemment puisqu'on sera beaucoup
dehors évidemment les comportements nos
comportements vont jouer énormément dans
cette affaire est aussi l'efficacité
toujours dû tester tracé isolé qui
devraient être poursuivis pendant cette
période de quelques mois
c'est bête ça m'irait qu'effectivement
l'autre problème qui est pointée par le
rapport du conseil scientifique c'est
que pour l'instant pour re trop peu de
français sont vaccinés alors si d'un
point de vue économique d'un point de
vue de la santé mentale de beaucoup de
points de vue on comprend tout à fait la
volonté de réouverture du gouvernement
est ce que ce n'est pas prématuré
d'un strict point de vue sanitaire par
rapport à cette question d'aider
vaccinant des vaccinations la
vaccination elle et s'est accéléré on a
eu quand même la semaine dernière j'ai
dû avoir plus de 3 millions de
vaccinations maintenant on a 18 millions
première injection
et puis 15% de la population qui a reçu
les deux injections
donc on est on est en augmentation
constante
le les centres de vaccination sont
accueille beaucoup de publier que
d'ailleurs remercié tous les soignants
qui se mobilisent par rapport à ça parce
que on voit qu'il ya une belle
collaboration entre les secouristes les
soignants les pompiers l'armée et on
voit qu'il ya une engagement très très
fort des soignants autour de retour de
ces de lactation
donc en tant qu'investisseur animateurs
jeu
je prône vraiment et notre traitement
c'est la vaccination il faut vacciner
vacciner vacciner parce que ça prévient
90% des formes graves et ce qu'on
souhaite c'est que les patients ne se
contaminent pas les personnes se
contaminent pas et du coup qui ne
viennent pas en réanimation pour faire
une forme grave parce que ce n'est
jamais anodin de faire une de faire de
la copie et puis de faire une forme
grave et d'être admis en réanimation
donc nous on sait ce qu'on souhaite on
souhaite que ça continue un et qu'on
arrive à faire baisser ses six chaînes
de transmission
donc on est dans une phase intermédiaire
on compte beaucoup sur l'été aussi les
le breton qui va arriver
et puis toujours les mesures de
prévention que maintenant
nous appliquions tout ça c'est pas parce
qu'on est vacciné qu'il ne faut pas
porter le masque faut pas avoir des
distanciation social comme nous comme
nous l'appliquons depuis maintenant un
peu plus d'un an
nous gardons d'ailleurs le masque ici
jusqu en plateau juste un mot sur la
vaccination à ce que vous jugez que ça
c'est vraiment aliot améliorée que ça
vraiment accéléré sur vos territoires à
chacun alors qu aujourd'hui et demain
s'ouvre la vaccination pour tous lorsque
les créneaux sont disponibles 24 heures
à l'invention en salade bas à partir du
moment où il ya un peu plus d'abondance
de vaccin ça va mieux forcément il ya eu
à un moment donné une concurrence
relative entre le généraliste le
pharmacien le vaccine aux drogues
le petit centre de vaccination là aussi
ça parle forcément été très fluide du
moins pour les usagers et et pour vous
quand un jeune et vous je sais qu'il ya
une vraie amélioration puisqu'on est
quand même on est passé à une gestion et
une accélération qui est qui est très
nette moi je souscris est ce qui a été
dit sur l'importance de la vaccination
mais la vaccination faut toujours
rappeler c'est un outil un outil
formidable un outil indispensable il
faut l'utiliser sans réserve
mais ce n'est pas une fin en soi la fin
en soi c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait avec
ce virus est ce qu'on accepte qu'ils
continuent même en épargnant les
personnes vulnérables même en épargnant
de réanimation a circulé de façon
relativement importante dans le pays ou
pas et qu'elle est calé l'arbitrage
entre cette circulation est ce que
personne ne souhaite d'ailleurs des
mesures restrictives les autres mesures
personne n'a envie on sait effectivement
le coût pour notre pays pour notre
société
mais il peut y avoir un coût aussi a
laissé trop de vie reste circulez y
compris en termes de ré émergence de
nouveaux variants et puis de personnes
notre collègue là à plat la rapporter
qui font des formes sévères qui auront
déco vide long et même si elle ne sature
pas les animations et bien ça fait
beaucoup de dégâts quand même
en tout cas pour l'instant est bien le
choix de l'exécutif c'est bien la
réouverture pour le 19 mai à paris comme
à rennes
vous allez le voir l'heure est au
soulagement et à l'impatience pour les
restaurateurs même s'ils attendent eux
avant tout la deuxième étape celle du 9
juin écoutez j'ai envie de bosser en
fait donc au terme de toutes façons je
vais pas pouvoir reprendre tout mon
personnel pour l'instant j'ai vu on va
être et en effectif très très très très
très très très réduit moi je vais tout
seul je me reprends pas de perso mort
salle juste avec mon chef
aujourd'hui on est content de démarrer
avec les terrasses malheureusement il ya
toute une partie des établissements sont
majoritaires qui n'ont pas de terrasse
donc il faut quand même rapidement
qu'henry ouvre l'intérieur et donc ça
c'est à partir du 9 juin
alors ces restaurateurs se prépare vous
l'entendez plutôt à la réouverture du 9
juin
car le 19 mai seuls les terrasses seront
rouvertes à 50% avec un maximum de 6
personnes par table les salles elles
seront rouvertes à partir du 9 juin
il va y avoir et bien par exemple une
jauge de vie m² à 10 mètres carrés par
client en magasin et noter également que
pour les salles de spectacle et les
cinémas et seront rouverts avec une
jauge de 35% et un maximum de 800
personnes jean-pierre série cette
ouverture elle est très progressive à ce
qu'elle est pour vous suffisamment
prudentes
on attend les restaurateurs qui
attendent le 9 juin avec impatience pour
pouvoir rouvrir à l'intérieur est ce que
pour vous c'est le bon timing
si vous voulez ce qui est un bon timing
avant d'être dans les mérités collective
ya des pays qui ont opté pour le zéro co
vie des contraintes de circulation et il
ya d'autres comme le nôtre qui ne
pouvaient ou qui l'adopté donc il ya des
alternances d'ouverture fermeture alors
là on peut pas maintenir trop longtemps
réalité une fermeture strictes
donc en résumé j'ai de réouvrir c'est ce
qu'on appelle tout ce que je disais le
mot stop and go
donc tout dépend dans les conditions de
la réouverture que comme ça a été dit de
l'adhésion de la population de notre
adhésion à l'ensemble des barrières
mesure est l'application l'ensemble des
mesures qui sont préconisées donc je
peux pas vous dire plus après on aura un
oeil sur les indicateurs en permanence
cl
vous savez le taux de contamination
repasse malgré l'été au dessus de 1 à
1,2 le problème ça va être la tension
sur verre animations et sur l'hôpital et
si on est obligé de refermer dirt
confiné même partiellement même si c'est
territoriales ce sera en fonction de ce
critère c'est à dire la saturation des
animations qui je le rappelle aussi
induit des déprogrammations de soins
c'est-à-dire touche beaucoup de gens au
delà malheureusement de ceux qui sont
touchés par les formes sévères et
parfois mortelle de kobe et refermer
confiné au niveau territorial le
gouvernement d'ailleurs se gardent cette
carte avec son projet de loi de sortie
de l'état d'urgence pour un état
transitoire
florence lassarade dont ce texte vous
avez commencé à en parler tout à l'heure
le gouvernement prévoit la mise en place
d'un pass sanitaires il sera nécessaire
d'une part pour voyager dans l'union
européenne ces acquis au niveau européen
mais aussi pour avoir accès en france a
de grands lieux de rassemblement
excédant 1000 personnes hier à
l'assemblée bien ça fait de grands
débats il a été rejeté dans un premier
temps adopté après une deuxième
délibération est ce que vous vous y êtes
personnellement favorable priori j'y
suis plutôt favorable ce que là aussi je
regrette c'est qu'on soit toujours un
petit peu à la traîne pourquoi on est
venu au pass annie terre parce que nos
collègues nos voisins européens le
préconise donc pour voyager il va lui
falloir du coup on se dit allez on peut
y aller on a en même temps passe tous
antique au vide sur nos téléphones
portables on se dit ça vous pourra
fonctionner mais pourquoi ne pas avoir
utilisé le dossier médical partagé moi
je suis pédiatre depuis longtemps je
réclame le carnet de vaccination sur le
dossier médical va se partager ça serait
beaucoup plus simple et comment est-ce
qu'on va aller chercher moi j'ai fait ma
première dose début début janvier j'ai
pas pu
l'intégré intéressions à mellila ne
vienne d'eux a été faite aussi quand je
vais vouloir sortir mon passani terre
comment ça va se passer et je suis un
cas particulier mais il n'y a en france
que des cas particuliers tout est tous
pareils il ya beaucoup de personnes à
évacuer des mois de janvier au mois de
février peut-être à des moments c'était
pas encore administrativement aussi près
quoi après globalement cc c'est bien de
proposer le pass and i ter à condition
que tout le monde est accès au vaccin
on espère que qu'on va pouvoir à classer
un test négatif encore suffi pour jour
avant deux jours avant ce faire le fer
trifouiller le nez ou faire la même note
aux tests c'est compliqué quand même
malgré tout c'est des tracasseries
comment est-ce qu'on va de façon simple
présenter ce pass sanitaires c'est un
outil est ce que vous comprenez certains
parlementaires qui jugent le pass
sanitaire discriminatoire bernard jomier
on a entendu un des débats hier à
l'assemblée où ici au sénat et
d'ailleurs qui vont jusqu'à atteindre la
majorité présidentielle bon d'abord
toutes opinions légitime pour le
rappeler en démocratie mais je trouve
qu'on vit dans une société qui a poussé
l'individualisme jusqu'à oublier que le
vaccin s'il protège ni pour nous
protéger individuellement est aussi un
acte de protection la collectivité parce
qu'ils contribuent à rompre les chaînes
de transmission
et dire que c'est une atteinte
insupportable à la liberté que d'être
vacciné qu'on veut faire société
c'est nous renvoyer à notre sein une
condition de simple individu
or quand on veut aller n'est pas
obligatoire bernard jomier on a aussi et
c'est justement c'est mieux que ce soit
une volonté partagée toujours
l'obligation ça ne peut être que quand
des personnes en nombre trop important
sont rétives à une volonté partagée et
la volonté partagée et ça doit être de
sortir ce virus de notre société et donc
il faut que nous adhérions la
vaccination pour nous mêmes mais pour
les autres et pas que pour notre grand
père ou notre famille mais pour notre
société c'est un acte aussi d'une
certaine forme d'altruisme alors ça
paraît peut-être désuet mais je trouve
que l'obligation vaccinale
existe au jour d'aujourd'hui et c'est
pas une atteinte intolérable à la
liberté il ya des défections obligatoire
mais sommes tous les quatre médecins je
crois nous sommes tous obligés d'être
vaccinée contre l'hépatite b c'est comme
ça et c'est pas une heure où on ne se
lève pas le matin en se disant mais
c'est insupportable on attend à notre
liberté qu'est cette société qui
n'arrivent plus à édicter une règle de
protection commune et le pass sanitaires
il faut leur rappeler c'est soit le
vaccin en plus soit si on ne veut
vraiment pas
j'en ai absolument réactif c'est faire
un test pour simplement garantir que si
vous allez dans un festival où il ya
3000 personnes vous n'allez pas
contaminer les autres
et vous trouvez que c'est insupportable
de vous demander de prendre cette simple
précaution
moi je trouve qu'il ya un égoïsme
sociétal qui relayait politiquement et
qui me pose problème
sébastien amérique pour vous est ce
qu'il ya des risques de dérive avec le
passé ni terre en a entendu des
parlementaires je le disais est compris
dans la majorité qui sont hostiles qui
craignent que ça puisse être utilisé non
pas seulement pour les rassemblements de
1000 personnes il a fallu mettre bien
des garde-fous dans le texte pour dire
eh bien non il n'y aura pas besoin d'un
pass l'ani terre pour aller au
restaurant pour les activités du
quotidien ce que vous comprenez ces
inquiétudes
mais ces inquiétudes sont importantes
mais je rejoins tout à fait ce qui a été
dit auparavant
il faut raisonner à titre collectif et
la vaccination est un acte à mon sens
citoyen aussi pour pour faire société ça
ça me paraît important et en tant que
médecin anesthésiste réanimateur en tant
que médecin on doit avoir ce discours là
c'est un discours de prévention avant
d'être malade
eh bien il faut prévenir cette maladie
et c'est bien plus simple de traiter une
maladie avant qu'elle arrive donc moi je
promets ce côté là le pass sanitaires il
faut hessel a été dit aussi c'est un
outil un outil qui doit être cadrée mais
qui doit être bien cadré par la loi et
qui doit être utilisé en plus il n'est
pas complètement fermée parce qu'on peut
effectivement avoir la paix serre on
peut avoir la vaccination ont peu à voir
si on a été contaminé a un c'est une
attestation de non contagion et de
de remise de remise en état donc
clairement il est ici il faut que ça
soit tiendrais faut que ça soit
tiendrais il faut que ça soit anticipée
talent on parlait d' anticipation en
tout cas au niveau des soignants on est
en anticipation nom est extrêmement
vigilants sur les chiffres à venir et c5
qui nous importe beaucoup il ya la
réanimation n'y a pas que la réanimation
ya tous ces chiffres d'incidence pour
connaît maintenant et on va être
extrêmement vigilant à ça et j'en
profite pour souligner là aujourd'hui
c'est la journée internationale des
infirmiers
j'en profite pour les soigner pour les
remercier parce qu'en fait sans eux sans
les soignants on est médecin d'accord
mais sans l'ensemble des soignants toute
la chaîne eh bien on aurait eu du mal à
faire face à cette crise et j'espère
qu'on arrivera à bout et qu'on ne
reviendra pas à des situations
difficiles qu on a pu le traverser c'est
important effectivement de le rappeler
le rôle toujours des personnels
soignants qui sont sur le pont depuis
maintenant plus d'un an effectivement et
qui eux méritent toute notre
reconnaissance
on va rejoindre tout de suite alexandre
poussard vous êtes avec la sénatrice
eliane assassi présidente du groupe
communiste
elle est très méfiante à l'égard du
passé ni terre ici eh bien tous les
médecins qui aussi m'entourent
parlementaire ils sont plutôt favorables
oui il y en a ça ci est ce que vous êtes
favorable à ce pas sanitaire qui va
permettre d'organiser notre
déconfinement dans plusieurs semaines
pour être sincère je dois dire que moi
je me satisfais que des personnes et
notamment les jeunes puissent se
retrouver des moments festifs culturels
sportifs
je m'interroge quand même sur le pass
sanitaire est a priori je suis opposé
parce que j'ai l'impression à entendre
le gouvernement eut les débats
l'assemblée nationale que tout est fait
pour rendre la vaccination obligatoire
est ma deuxième question c'est qui va
contrôler celles et ceux qui seraient
vaccinés à l'entrée de ces de ces
événements donc deuxième question si on
nous invite à télécharger l'application
stock co vide il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a que 13 millions
de personnes qui ont téléchargé cette
application
que par ailleurs un français sur cinq
n'a pas de smartphone donc ça c'est une
autre question et l'autre est
scientifiquement qui va contrôler tout
ça donc votre avis et définitive vous
voterez compte se passer ni teurs je
pense effectivement qu'on votera contre
ce pas sanitaires et je dois dire que la
séquence d'hier à l'assemblée nationale
ne redore pas le blason le blason du
débat démocratique et on voit bien qu'il
y a un gros problème autour de cet
article premier dans sa globalité pas
simplement le pass sanitaire donc
j'espère qu'ici au sénat nous aurons des
débats sérieux approfondi est en tout
cas sur cet aspect là je m'y opposerai
pas ce que le gouvernement avait fait
des annonces sur le fait que la
vaccination ne serait pas obligatoire et
j'ai l'impression que il crée des
conditions pour qu'elle le devienne
et ça ce ne serait pas acceptable c'est
une rupture d'égalité et d'équité
mais est ce que cette vaccination ce
certificat de vaccination pour entrer à
l'avenir dans certains lieux publics
est-ce que c'est pas un geste altruiste
pour protéger les autres quand on va
continuer à revivre normalement dans
plusieurs mois mais je vous le répète
c'est une rupture d'égalité entre les
citoyens
c'est à dire que et on ouvre une boîte
de pandore donc aujourd'hui c'est celles
et ceux qui sont qui seraient vaccinés
contre celles et ceux qui ne le seront
pas sur la cabine dont vaccin contre la
copie de 19 mais demain ça peut être
autre chose ça pouvait traduire eu ça
peut être une autre maladie etc
donc on june moi j'ai dit attention
attention on est en train d'ouvrir une
boîte de pandore qui peut être très
dangereuse et conduire à des finalités
qui remettraient quand même en cause un
certain nombre de références à d'autres
packs donc justement pour éviter cette
généralisation dans d'autres cas du
passé annie terre vous allez peut-être
proposer un moment pour mettre des
limites dans le projet louable de la
semaine prochaine c'est pas des limites
d'abord c'est de dire qu'il y est opposé
et après moi il ya une chose à coquelles
à laquelle je crois vraiment
profondément ce sont les gestes barrière
je crois que la solution elle est là
c'est de créer les conditions
effectivement que les gestes barrière
devienne universel qu'il soit respecté
par tous et que on le voit bien ça
contribue à éradiquer le virus ce virus
voire même semblé vario de ce
de ce virus ce dont on est moins sûr
quand même avec les avec tvac s'agissant
des bryans bien évidemment merci
beaucoup et bien s'associent pour votre
réaction
et vous le voyez tam le débat la semaine
prochaine sur le pass sanitaire
s'annonce un peu animé il va y avoir un
débat bernard jomier juste un mot sur ce
que vient de dire eliane assassi elle
estime que le passé ni terre entraîne
une rupture d'égalité elle croit elle
dans les gestes barrière moi je suis
jamais constaté que la vaccination
contre la poliomyélite qui est
obligatoire dans notre pic a permis
d'égaliser d'effacer cette maladie et
porter atteinte à notre pacte
républicain
il ya actuellement aux vaccins
obligatoires chez les enfants ça ne
porte pas atteinte à notre pacte
républicain tout au contraire parce que
du fait qu'ils sont obligatoires ils
sont pris en charge complètement et donc
c'est une mesure d'égalité dans la
prévention face aux maladies non c'est
vraiment vouloir s'opposer au
gouvernement à tout prix jusqu'à prôner
un individualisme un peu hors de propos
je trouve que c'est tout à fait excessif
elle est en outre bien dans ce texte qui
va être débattu la semaine prochaine au
sénat qui a été adopté il ya par
l'assemblée le gouvernement se garde la
possibilité de faire des confinement
locaux et il prévoit également de
pouvoir poursuivre à les couvre feux
jusqu'au 30 juin ses couvre feu ils vont
être progressivement décalée de 19
heures aujourd'hui à 21h le 19 mai 23h
le 9 juin et 30 le 30 juin c'est terminé
mais sébastien l'irak est ce que pour
vous le couvre-feu l'efficacité des
couvre feux d'un point de vue sanitaire
a fait ses preuves
en tout cas moi je peux vous parler de
l'expérience qu'on a sur la bourgogne
franche comté et on participe de manière
quotidienne avec l'agencé régionale de
santé à l'évaluation et la circulation
du virus et on a vu que unia des effets
et ça ça se confirme
un peu partout sur le territoire alors
avec des circulations plus importantes
dans certaines zones et donc c'est pour
ça qu'on va adapter et que le
gouvernement adaptera c'est ce qui a été
dit et si ce qui va continuer d'être
fait donc nous on va continuer de
veiller notre veille elle sera toujours
là
notre idée encore toujours c'est
d'anticiper
il est important ça a été soulevée tout
à l'heure il faut prendre en charge les
patients qu'aux vide il faut prendre en
charge aussi tous les patients donc au
vide et là très clairement on est en
pleine phase de reprogrammation et
d'adaptation pour qu' il n'est pas de
perte de chance pour l'ensemble des
patients et c'est ce qu'on fait depuis
un an et on va continuer à le faire
c'est extrêmement important pour nous
que l'ensemble des patients qui ont
besoin de soins
peu importe ce qu'ils ont comme
pathologie bas soit bien pris en charge
dans les bons centres et en bon moment
donc ça c'est aussi capitale pour vous c
est ce que pour vous un couvre-feu sur
tout le couvre feu lorsqu'il va être
décalé à 23 heures ça a un intérêt
on peut aussi penser que les gens
peuvent se rassembler les uns chez les
autres pour respecter le couvre-feu mais
on sait aussi que c'est peut-être chez
soi qu'on se relâche le plus en termes
de comportement on pourra répondre à ça
qu en regardant l'évolution des
indicateurs qui évidemment va être
impactée par la rapidité de la
vaccination
donc je peux pas vous dire autre chose
qu on verra il ya eu certainement un
effet au couvre-feu dans ce cas a été
constatée d'abord en guyane et ensuite
dans quelques départements mais c'est un
ensemble de mesures qui doivent être
prises et encore une fois c'est des
comportements individuels qui feront les
différences de l'ensemble des acteurs y
compris de ceux qui organisera des
mariages les fêtes que vraiment les
restaurants mais encore une fois si vous
voulez les effets de la vaccination et
votes très importants dans le temps mais
ne chante pas mais il ya ils sont
décalés dans le temps par opposition à
confinement strict à un effet quasiment
très rapide et ça c est donc la
différence entre être obligé de refaire
un confinement strict sous pression
notamment de saturation derrière et un
relâchement progressif
ça va être le suivi des indicateurs
florence lassarade un mot pour conclure
sur le projet de loi qui va être
examinée la semaine prochaine on voit
aussi qu'il ya tout un débat autour et
bien des pouvoirs un qu'il donne au
gouvernement notamment et bien cette
possibilité de pouvoir prononcer
déconfinement locaux de pouvoir
maintenir un couvre-feu et cela alors
même qu on sera sorti de l'état
d'urgence stricto sensu est ce que pour
vous ce sont des pouvoirs exorbitants
donné au gouvernement où est-ce qu'ils
sont justifiées par la crise que nous
traversons je suis assez à l'aise
tu parce que j'étais la seule
parlementaire a pas avoir voté les
pleins pouvoirs en mars 2020 je crois
que ce qui est important là c'est con
quand on donne les points les pleins
pouvoirs on le donne sur tous les sujets
est-ce qu'on devrait pas se cantonner
aux sujets sanitaires et est ce qu'on ne
devrait pas donner sa place au parlement
qu'elle n'a plus depuis des mois sur ce
sujet je crois que c'est vraiment là là
que le bât blesse le dialogue a le
contrôle parlementaire et je pense
pourtant qu'on peut on le voit dans ce
débat a porté
la contradiction et la réflexion on
serait notre pays en serait plus fort
bernard jomier vous votre sentiment
là-dessus est ce que c'est normal de
donner ses pouvoirs là au gouvernement
avec ce nouveau texte qui va être
examinée la semaine prochaine
est-ce que vous avez l'impression
d'ailleurs qu'avec ce texte on sort
vraiment de l'état d'urgence ou pas pas
vraiment et je pense que plus le temps
passe plus il faut revenir au droit
commun et il faut inscrire d'ailleurs
dans notre dans notre vie commune
collectif le fait que oui lutter contre
une épidémie doit être l'objet de
process tout à fait j'allais dire
normaux c'était acceptable pour moi
j'avais accepté au début de la crise
condom vote cet état d'urgence sanitaire
mais maintenant que le temps a passé je
pense que la demande du gouvernement est
excessive et irrespectueuse du parlement
et au fond l'ensemble de la société
eh bien merci merci beaucoup à tous les
quatre d'avoir participé à ce débat nous
sommes maintenant à une demi heure des
questions au gouvernement
nos journalistes sont en place voyez
alexandre poussard qui se trouvait salle
des conférences
jean massiet sur twitch avec et sa
communauté et quentin qu'elle met dans
l'hémicycle du sénat c'est l'heure de
nous donner un peu plus de détails
quentin sur le programme de cet après
midi eh bien on va largement revenir sur
le malaise des policiers au lendemain de
la cérémonie qui a eu lieu à avignon
après la mort du brigadier maçons cette
cérémonie avec 300 personnes dans la
cour la préfecture du vaucluse où
étaient deux sénateurs le centriste loïc
hervé et le sénateur à l'ère jean
baptiste blanc ces deux sénateurs vont
poser aujourd'hui des questions
les alertes par exemple vont demander
d'arrêter les grands discours mais de
donner davantage de moyens à la police
et à la justice
ils vont dénoncer également une ultra
violence je cite jean baptiste blanc qui
touche les petites villes et les petits
territoires dès lundi soir jean castex a
annoncé un durcissement des peines
encourues par les autres les agresseurs
de policiers et notamment à une peine de
sûreté de trente ans pour les personnes
condamnées à la perpétuité pour un crime
commis contre les forces de l'ordre
et hier il a aussi été question de du
refus d'obtempérer 1 c'est une annonce
qui a été faite hier
au 20 heures de france 2 jean castex a
dit que et bien ce refus d'obtempérer
sera plus durement punis mais on attend
à 15 heures plus de précisions de la
part du premier ministre du gouvernement
a passé
merci merci beaucoup quentin pour toutes
ces explications vous retrouve dans
moins de 30 minutes maintenant pour le
début de ces questions d'actualité en
attendant on va parler et bien de ce
thème que vous venez d'évoquer on va
paraître sécurité sur ce plateau
un thème qui s'annonce comme l'un des
enjeux majeurs des enjeux clés de la
campagne présidentielle qui va être très
bien quand on l'a dit plusieurs fois
abordée dans l'hémicycle cet après midi
cela alors que deux policiers ont été
tués en deux jours et ça pose de
nombreuses questions sur comment
répondre au malaise des forces de
l'ordre on dit gay la violence dans les
quartiers ou encore cela interroge sur
est bien la question de l'autorité de
l'état on va parler de tout cela avec
deux invités sur ce plateau valérie
boyer bonjour sénatrice et les
républicains des bouches du rhône est
également avec n'examinera covelli jean
sénateurs r&d pays le groupe de la
majorité présidentielle ici au sénat des
hauts-de-seine d'abord et bien
l'exécutif attaqué notamment par la
droite sur le terrain de la sécurité
quelles réponses apporte-t-il en va cela
elle a créé bien ricker à un an de
l'élection présidentielle
emmanuel macron veut occuper le terrain
de la sécurité
comme il l'annonçait au figaro le mois
dernier chaque français verra plus de
bleus sur le terrain en 2022 qu'en 2017
ça rassure les gens ça dissuade les
délinquants dernier épisode en date de
cette offensive
un nouveau projet de loi antiterroriste
présenté aujourd'hui en conseil des
ministres il avait été annoncé au
lendemain de l'attentât de rambouillet
par le premier ministre la république
entend continuer à se donner tous les
moyens pour lutter pied à pied contre le
terrorisme islamique un texte qui vient
renforcer l'arsenal déployé par le
gouvernement après l'adoption de la loi
sécurité globale l'examen du projet de
loi contre le séparatisme et la promesse
de recruter dix mille policiers et
gendarmes
le gouvernement veut enfin durcir les
peines en cas d'agression contre les
forces de l'ordre suite à la mort d'un
brigadier lors d'une opération anti
drogue avis
vu la succession des faits divers des
agressions de policiers de gendarmes des
drames qui touchent nos compatriotes il
peut y avoir ya pu avoir un doute et je
crois que le premier ministre le
ministre la justice moi-même nous levons
se doute la main ferme de l'état ne
tremblera pas et nous sommes du côté des
policiers des gendarmes
quitte à donner l'impression de
gouverner au gré de l'actualité
l'exécutif entend surtout contrer le
procès en laxisme que lui font le rn et
les républicains valérie boyer on a
entendu gérald darmanin qui parle de la
main ferme de l'état qui ne tremblera
pas l'exécutif à muscler l'arsenal
législatif en plus de la loi sécurité
globale de la loi séparatisme voilà et
bien aujourd'hui présenté un nouveau
projet de loi antiterroriste il ne
ménage pas ses efforts le gouvernement
est ce que vous le reconnaissez ce que
c'est suffisant écoutez je comprends pas
bien ce qui se passe aujourd'hui à la
commission mixte paritaire sur la loi
sur les valeurs de la république voilà
c'est la loi la loi séparatisme a dit je
ne sais pas ce qu'il va sortir du
chapeau de la cmp
sébastien nalcor oui j'espère j'espère
que les propositions du sénat ne vont
pas être balayé d'un revers de main par
la majorité en marche c'est le premier
point parce que dans ce texte
nous avions des choses très importantes
pour le respect des valeurs de la
république et le réarmement moral aussi
de ces valeurs afin de les faire
respecter ses premiers points le
deuxième point je note que pour tous
étaient les textes sécurité nous avons
fait de nombreuses propositions la loi
colons la nouvelle loi du nouveau
ministre de l'intérieur est que la
plupart n'ont pas été retenus donc c'est
qu'il ya des textes et pour vous ils ne
vont pas assez loin je pense qu'ils ne
vont pas assez loin et je vais vous
citer un exemple
un exemple tout simple qui a trait aussi
avec l'actualité je pense à l'actualité
de mérignac
vous vous souvenez que nous avons votée
en 2010 il y avait
les braises les bracelets électroniques
anti-rapprochement imart pour les
violences conjugales
non non c'était la loi et dont il au
froid mais bon les bracelets anti
rapprochement a été votée moi j'ai fait
voter au sénat une augmentation de 2,7
millions d'euros une enveloppe allouée
au bracelet anti rapprochement
et voilà que j'apprends à l'occasion de
ce sinistre drame de mérignac que nous
avons sur 1000 bracelet anti
rapprochement qui existe depuis leur
lancement effectif en 2000 seuls 76 ont
été prescrits et seulement 45 hommes en
sont équipés donc on voit bien qu'il y à
des actes va d un discours et puis il ya
des actes qui volontairement cet exemple
pour pour vraiment si tu es quelque
chose de très content la proche de là je
rajoute un puisqu'on apprend aujourd'hui
également que gérald darmanin un fichier
1 pour faire face aux violences
conjugales à la suite et les règlements
de la faire je n'aurais jamais pagnol
c'est à des amendements que j'avais fait
voter via covelli votre réaction vous
également sur ce fichier
autour d'eux les violences conjugales
puisque c'est la non ce que l'on vient
d'apprendre à l'instant
alors que et bien il ya eu un nombre de
défaillances effectivement qui ont été
vus après eh bien cette affaire de
mérignac et ce terrible un art rang
écoutez moi ce que je vois effectivement
c'est que ça va dans le bon sens avoir
un fichier national sur les actes de
violence conjugale c'est comme ça moi je
le demande dans le cadre de la
protection de l'enfance d'avoir un
fichier national également sur la
question des violences sur enfants ce
que nous n'avons pas encore et donc
effectivement moi je pense que nous
polluons mutualisent dans nos forces de
police
rendre la police la justice ont utilisé
des informations plus effectivement on
est efficace moi je vois quand même un
gouvernement qui est à l'offensive sur
la question de la sécurité qui n'a pas
attendu d'ailleurs malheureusement ces
drames pour être à l'offensive
parce que quand on annonce en début du
quinquennat qu'on allait recruter dix
mille forces de police supplémentaires
ça ne se fait pas du jour au lendemain
aujourd'hui on est à presque 7000 de
recruter on sera à 10 milles d'ici la
fin du quinquennat
donc on voit bien que dès 2017
nous avons pris à bras le corps la
question de la sécurité et puis
effectivement ces drames qui arrivent
aujourd'hui sont aussi le résultat d'une
action plus virulente
un coup de pied dans la fourmilière pour
reprendre les propos de la gabriela
talent sur les points de deal 4000
points de deal en france 1700 qui ont
été démantelés 4000 trafiquants qui ont
été arrêtés c'est aussi malheureusement
le résultat d'une action forte du
gouvernement
alors juste un mot sur les violences
conjugales c'est comme une satisfaction
si le gouvernement arrive oui pour ses
positions mais moi je m'en réjouis mais
je voudrais qu'on passe des paroles aux
actes
et l'exemple que je vous donnais très
concret n'y aura ses lektronix en détail
en a un deuxième j'ai été nommé à une
commission pour le suivi pour le
logement les difficultés d'hébergement
pour les femmes battues
ça fait des mois et j'attends toujours
voilà aussi quelque chose
j'aimerais bien que ce soit concrètes
pour répondre à mon collègue
effectivement mais j'ai un chiffre mois
sur il ya plus sans violence par jour
une hausse de 21 % en trois ans pour les
policiers des gendarmes
donc on est bien sûr une violence très
particulière et on ne peut pas
simplement dire qu'aujourd'hui la
violence contre les policiers les
gendarmes contre les dépositaires de
l'autorité publique
et bien c'est uniquement parce que on
les jeunes dans leurs points de deal on
voit bien que c'est quelque chose qui
est beaucoup plus profond ça va beaucoup
plus loin
c'est l'expression d'un rejet de
l'autorité d'une sorte de haine de la
france qui est exprimé dans certains
dans certains endroits
et quand on voit la multiplication des
endroits où des émeutes ont eu lieu y
compris dans la ville du ministre de
l'intérieur il ya quelques semaines
pendant trois ou quatre jours
on ne peut que s'inquiéter moi j'ai fait
un petit récap des villes où ça s'est
passé c'est sur tout le territoire
français
dans des villes comme fréjus
rillieux-la-pape tourcoing bon ben je
sais pas brouains jallieu mais aimer
d'autres que j'ai oublié je suis quand
même
effaré de voir la constance la
multiplication la violence les pièges
dans lesquels
les guets-apens dont sont victimes les
forces de l'ordre aujourd'hui c'est
quelque chose c'est un phénomène dont
l'ampleur est nouvelle et ça va bien
plus loin que les perturbations soient
de points de deal on va parler
d'ailleurs de ce malaise policier
puisque effectivement il s'installe
encore une fois du côté des forces de
l'ordre après que deux d'entre eux
notamment vous n'avez pas eu de
nombreuses villes ont été tuées à
rambouillet à avignon et on va rejoindre
alexandre poussin car vous êtes avec
loïc hervé sénateur centriste
il va tout à l'heure interpellé le
gouvernement à ce sujet lors de la
séance de questions
effectivement avec harvey vous aller
interpeller le gouvernement sur cette
lassitude des policiers face aux
violences contre les forces de l'ordre
les gens mot sur la réponse du
gouvernement jean castex qui annonce un
durcissement des sanctions judiciaires
avec par exemple une peine de sûreté de
trente ans de prison pour les auteurs de
crimes contre les forces de l'ordre
c'est la bonne réponse de la part du
premier ministre je crois que tout ce
qui pourrait annoncer en direction des
forces de l'ordre pour rétablir la
confiance entre l'état c'est à dire le
l'exécutif le parlement et les forces de
l'ordre nous qui représentons le le
peuple nous avons besoin d'envoyer un
message vis-à-vis des forces de sécurité
des policiers de gendarmes pour leur
dire que nous prenons en considération
ce ras-le-bol qu'ils expriment ça c'est
la première des choses
moi je dirais que c'est ce message
envoyé par le gouvernement il doit aussi
être confronté à une réalité qui est le
fait que les décisions de justice
doivent être prononcés avec sévérité et
être accompli avec sévérité ça c'est un
vrai sujet dans notre pays parce qu'on
voit bien que avec les destinations des
remises de peine avec les guildes la
question de de l'absence de places en
prison même parfois ces délinquants là
qui vont agressé des policiers des
gendarmes ne vont pas purgé leur peine
donc ça c'est une vraie un vrai sujet
judiciaires pénitentiaires qui est très
important dans la loi sécurité globale
dont j'étais le rat le rapporteur ici
avec marc philippe daubresse
nous avons trouvé un accord avec nos
collègues députés pour mettre fin dans
un certain nombre de cas aux remises de
peine automatiques et ça et ça va être
un jeu pensé tendue dans le projet de
loi que porte le garde des sceaux
ça c'est aussi très quelque chose de
très important pour si vous voulez avoir
un effet de sévérité vis à vis de ces
personnes là je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui est tout à fait positif sur
les remises de peine automatiques on le
précise c'est quand une personne
condamnée arrivent en prison il
un crédits automatiques de réduction de
peine et s'il se comporte bien non c'est
en deux niveaux
si vous êtes condamné à une peine de
prison vous avez automatiquement une
remise de peine et si vous vous
comportez bien vous avez encore une
autre
et justement ces dispositions ainsi tu
as bien sûr fortement à la réinsertion
des détenus
bien sûr bien sûr et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut ne pas les supprimer pour tout le
monde et pour tous les délits mais pour
les délits à l'égard des policiers des
gendarmes
ça nous est apparu important d'avoir
cette ce mécanisme la de suppression des
remises de peine automatiques et je
préfère ça à des dispositifs de peines
plancher ou de peines automatiques ou le
magistrat n'intervient plus et où par
rapport à un délit dans le code pénal on
a une peine automatique
ça c'est le début d'un arbitraire ça
sert même plus à rien devant des juges
devant des ordinateurs qui condamne les
gens donc et y ont plutôt eu un
renforcement de l'arsenal pénal et
surtout que les décisions des juges soit
appliquée avec toute la sévérité qui est
qui est exigé et justement vous parliez
de ses peines minimales automatiques
elles sont proposées par vos collègues
des républicains qui veulent même
changer la constitution pour que elles
deviennent possibles ça vous inquiète
ce type de propositions de la part de la
droite toute dérive sécuritaire maquette
en soi parce que moi je suis attaché à
l' équilibre des pouvoirs et au fait que
les magistrats dans notre pays garants
des libertés publiques doivent protéger
les victimes
mais doit aussi se rendre une justice
qui soit une justice qui qui prennent en
compte tout un tas d'éléments donc les
juges ils doivent y doivent appliquer la
loi que nous votons ici mais doivent le
faire évidemment en tenant compte de
tout un tas de deux paramètres et c'est
normal donc renforçons la loi mais
faisons appliquer les décisions mais de
grâce ne ne supprimons pas toute la
légitimité des juges qui est justement
d'apprécier au nom du peuple souverain
les situations auxquelles elles sont
soumises
merci beaucoup elle est hervé d'avoir
répondu à mes questions c'est à vous
tous merci beaucoup alexandre vous aviez
à cofely jean castex a annoncé un volet
de mesures pour renforcer les peines à
l'encontre des agresseurs de policiers
ça doit passer par quel mécanisme
puisque là eh bien on vient d'en parler
à l'instant est ce qu il faut d des
peines minimales automatique revenir
terme enfin en finir avec la question
des remises de peine automatiques par
quel mécanisme est déjà le premier
ministre l'a annoncé
et je pense que les français attendaient
aussi cette réponse parce que
ça ne peut concevoir qu'on puisse
agressé des forces de police ou d'autres
être condamné par un juge à une certaine
peine et avoir des remises de peine
automatiques
soit parce qu'elles soient automatiques
soit par bonne conduite ça les français
ne le comprennent pas et ne l'acceptent
pas et donc le premier ministre annonce
est effectivement la fin des remises de
peine pour toutes les agressions les
crimes et les agressions sur les forces
de sécurité intérieure ça c'est déjà le
premier point et je pense que c'est est
fortement attendue ensuite c'est la
suppression du rappel à loulle à la loi
qui entre nous soit dit faisait plutôt
rire les délinquants plutôt qu'autre
chose donc ça on arrête les rappels à la
drau à la loi et donc il ya
automatiquement saisie du juge des
référés auprès auprès du juge pour pour
ce genre d et puis il ya aussi ceux qui
sont condamnés à perpétuité pour des
crimes sur les forces de l'ordre sur les
forces de sécurité intérieures on passe
effectivement de 22 ans de sûreté
à 30 ans et de peine donc ça je pense
que c'est indispensable parce que ça
alourdit les peines face c'est un
élément aggravant d'attaquer aujourd'hui
nos forces de l'ordre et c'est un
message clair aussi du gouvernement de
l'exécutif vis-à-vis de nos forces de
sécurité qui nous protège tous les jours
mais ce panel de mesures exposées par
xavier iacovelli ce qu'elles sont
suffisantes notamment pour faire face et
bien aux agressions de policiers qu'est
ce que vous proposez valérie voyante
j'en sais rien parce qu'on n'a vraiment
on assiste même à une augmentation je le
disais tout à l'heure des agressions de
dépositaire de forces de l'ordre à des
guets-apens et c'est vrai que la prison
ne fait pas peur ce qui n'était pas le
cas il ya 20 30 ans lorsqu'on agressé un
policier on savait qu'on allait finir
ses jours en prison aujourd'hui c'est
pas le cas et j'ai écouté les
commentaires de vos confrères et
d'avocats suite au jugement pour nordine
le landais qui a pris donc 20 ans qui a
été condamné à 20 ans et des avocats
disent et condamné à 20 ans si on
applique toutes les mesures bonne
conduite remises de peine il fera 12 ans
voilà ce que vaut un crime
aujourd'hui en france en fait qu'est ce
que vous demandez la nuit
mul t on en finisse avec les remises les
belges dont elle garde et non parce que
pour ça il faudrait probablement changer
très profondément la loi oui puisque on
nous dit qu'il n'est pas possible que ce
soit quelque chose d'automatique moi
j'entends bien mais ce que je voudrais
c'est que quand une peine est prononcée
en france eh bien on ne dise pas que
quelqu'un est condamné à 20 ans par
exemple quand on sait parfaitement qu'il
va être qu'il ne va faire que 12 ans
donc ça aussi c'est quelque chose je
pense que quand on rend la justice au
nom du peuple français ce qui est le cas
aujourd'hui il faut dire aux français ce
qui est la réalité de l'exécution de la
peine
il faudrait dire 12 dans ce cadre là
pourquoi pas en tout cas changer les
choses parce qu'on ne peut pas mentir
aux français en permanence et ça ne sert
à rien d'annoncer des peines si elles ne
peuvent pas être exécutée pour les
raisons que nous venons d'évoquer
d'une part et d'autre part parce qu'on
n'a pas tenu ses engagements de campagne
emmanuel macron n'en a pas 10 100 1000
des engagements de campagne il en avait
1 c'était la construction de places de
prison
or aujourd'hui aujourd'hui les places de
prison qu'il avait promis en place de
prison effectives il y en a mille cinq
cents oui alors que pour qu'un maximum
juste je termine s'il vous plaît quittez
que pour exécuter les peines louis on
sait parfaitement et pour la dignité
aussi des personnes qui sont emprisonnés
eh bien il aurait fallu en construire
comme il l'avait promis d'autres
registres handicapés avec cette question
majeure
les moustiques avec l'opposition et
notamment les républicains c'est que
lorsqu'on fait des mesures qui vont dans
le sens effectivement qu'il demande
depuis les ailes que vous demandez plus
depuis des années alors même que nous
subissons et nous avons subi des
décennies de restrictions budgétaires
dont votre majorité l'ancienne majorité
l air sous nicolas sarkozy est
responsable
la réduction des postes la réduction des
budgets de la justice tout ça ce sont
aussi sous votre majorité
mais cependant
je suis enceinte et dix ans pour
répondre sur la question des places de
prison
je me noyais a dû oublier le plan qui a
été annoncé des plans de 15000 places de
prison dont 7500 qui vont être
construites d'ici 2023 donc ce 2023
c'est demain et c'est 4 5 milliards 15,5
milliards investis ok vous savez madame
doyer pour construire des prisons il
faut acheter le foncier en quatre ans
c'était madame belloubet match ne s'est
pas interrompue madame belloubet a
effectivement lancé ce plan lorsqu'elle
était garde des sceaux elle a trouvé les
places les emplacements les dix neuf
emplacements de foncier pour acheter le
foncier pour pouvoir construire ces
prisons et le plan a été lancé à la fin
du quinquennat on n'aura pas les places
de prisons promise effective ça c'est
une réalité et collectivement et
effectivement je rappelle quand même à
mon collègue que ça fait dix ans que
nous ne sommes plus les inscriptions et
que je voudrais pas aller dîner
lherminez parce que cette antienne et
quand même fatigante
je voudrais quand même rappeler que sous
nicolas sarkozy la délinquance avait
baissé et pratiquants et la délinquance
avait baissé et qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui le monde a changé depuis
2012 notamment parce que nous avons
affaire à deux choses très importantes
la première c'est la menace terroriste
qui est constante et très élevé en
france et la deuxième c'est quand même
là où migratoires dans lequel nous nous
trouvons aujourd'hui elle est le cas de
ce policier tué avignon est notamment
liée au trafic de drogue un gérald
darmanin
il ya beaucoup fait référence emmanuel
macron a fait de la lutte contre le
trafic de drogue une priorité nationale
mais il ya aussi et bien d'un autre côté
certains parlementaires de votre
majorité par exemple ou de la votera
également valérie boyer comme caroline
janvier ou en barrada qui veulent eux
ouvrir le débat sur la légalisation du
cannabis on va parler un petit peu de
trafic de drogue et l'égalisation mais
on va rejoindre jean macé avec sa
communauté sur twitter pour parler bien
de ce sujet puis d autres sujets
peut-être qui les préoccupent
aujourd'hui
et oui absolument tam tu t'en doutes les
les internautes ça les intéresse
énormément la question du débat sur le
cannabis on a vu l'an broglio qui a eu à
l'assemblée nationale sur ce sujet
hâte de voir ce que les sénateurs en
diront avec avec le gouvernement sait
notamment que la majorité n'avait pu
être marche à l'assemblée est divisée
sur ce sujet quoi qu'il en soit pour la
séance des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement cet après-midi les sujets
qui intéressent le plus les internautes
c'est la question du déconfinement
quelles sont les conditions de
réouverture des bars des discothèques de
cet été ça ça fait partie des sujets sur
lesquels les internautes veulent que le
gouvernement s'exprime la question du
pass sanitaires on a vu ce qui s'est
passé hier soir l'assemblée nationale
quel est le point de vue des sénateurs
sur ce sujet c'est aussi quelque chose
qui est attendu les thérapies de
conversion c'est aussi un sujet qui
intéresse beaucoup
figure-toi les internautes on a vu que
la reine d'angleterre a pris la pause il
a pris position en faveur de
l'interdiction des thérapies de
conversion en france elisabeth moreno la
ministre chargée de des droits des
femmes qui a qui a expliqué qu'elle
allait prendre une circulaire pour
limiter encore plus ces thérapies de
conversion qui vise les personnes
homosexuelles et enfin le dernier sujet
qui intéresse les internautes et dont il
aimerait bien entendre les sénateurs
parler avec le gouvernement cet après
midi c'est restée fameuse tribune de
militaires quelles sanctions contre les
militaires qui signent des tribune
appelant à la guerre civile voilà les
sujets qui sont attendus cet après-midi
table des sujets très variés donc gens
qui intéresse les internautes cet après
midi est notamment liée à la question de
la crise sanitaire on va parler d'un
autre sujet un sujet qui intéresse
beaucoup le sénat et sur lequel il va y
avoir une conférence de presse tout à
l'heure ce sujet c'est la question de
l'irresponsabilité pénale
alexandre pouchard vous êtes avec
françois noël buffet président de la
commission des lois plusieurs
parlementaires veulent changer l'âme loi
en matière d' irresponsabilité pénale la
sphère sarah halimi notamment est dans
toutes les têtes
c'est à vous mais oui l affaire ça
allait me qui a fait une grosse
polémique puisque la cour de cassation
avait décidé de rendre le meurtrier sara
lee me irresponsable pénalement alors
même que ce meurtrier était sous
l'emprise de cannabis au moment des
faits et donc il ya une réforme de
l'irresponsabilité pénale qui est
proposée aujourd'hui par les sénateurs
de la droite et du centre
quel est le but de cette réforme
françois noël buffet c'est de dire si on
commet un crime et qu'on a fumé du
cannabis ça lève automatiquement les
responsabilités pénales
oui on peut l'expliquer comme ça très
rapidement d'abord je voudrais dire que
l'arrêt de la cour de cassation en droit
il est parfait il ya rien à redire sur
le plan du droit n'ont fait qu'appliquer
le droit et il va impliquer le droit
positif
la question qui est soulevée c'est
quelqu'un qui volontairement s'est placé
dans une situation d'être une forme
d'inconscience au moment où il commet un
fait et notamment un crime et il est
déclaré responsable ou doit-il au
contraire comparaître à être jugé la
question de fond c'est que il n'est pas
fou en sont elles et comment apprécié au
moment de l'acte c'est la difficulté
donc il faut modifier la loi pour
permettre de poursuivre des personnes
qui sciemment se sont placés dans cette
situation
entre guillemets je simplifie très vite
de folie pour échapper quelque part à
l'irresponsabilité pénale dont tout le
travail est engagé
les deux textes qui viendront au sénat
la fin du mois un qui vient des
collections triste et un qui vient du
groupe et l'air mais pas seulement
en fait et est donc on devrait arriver à
trouver une solution juridique qui
permette de trouver véritablement les
moyens de condamner ceux qui sciemment
en tout cas qu'ils soient jugés ceux qui
sciemment ont essayé de se placer dans
une situation qui paradoxalement
pourrait déboucher aujourd'hui ses
responsabilités et pourtant il ya des
professionnels du monde judiciaire des
experts qui disent attention si on
touche à cet article 122 du code pénal
on risque de juger les fous ya un risque
avec une réforme comme celle ci dans le
début des auditions qui sont menées on
entend cette observation
elle est fondée il faut donc être très
prudents à la manière dont on va
réformer
donc on fera les propositions pour
aboutir à l'objectif que l'on souhaite
sans remettre en cause le fait que la
france ne juge pas les fous et c'est un
heureux d'ailleurs
donc on est vraiment sur un un équilibre
juridique une solution juridique qui
devrait arriver à remplir cet office et
je pense que dans les premières
réflexions on tient déjà un prochain
projet de solution
mais l'exécutif également va mener une
réforme sur les responsabilités pénales
ça avait été annoncée par emmanuel
macron juste après cette décision
polémique de la cour de cassation et ce
qui est un pas aussi le risque de l'est
ferris sous le coup de l'émotion de
l'émoi de l'opinion publique
vous connaissez le sénat le travail de
la commission en particulier est un
travail qui essaye de prendre à la fois
du sérieux de la sécurité juridique et
ne pas trop se laisser influencer par
l'ambiance générale quand bien même il
faille en tenir compte mais notre
travail sur un travail de fond d'abord
merci beaucoup merci tonton françois
noël buffet pour votre réaction
merci beaucoup alexandre est rapidement
une réaction survient cette question de
l'irresponsabilité pénale
comment est bien faut-il réformer cette
question de l'irresponsabilité pénale
est ce que c'est pour vous donner c'est
ça que vous aviez iacovelli on a entendu
dans certains experts disent attention
on risque aussi de juger les fous à
faire la loi chez vite
alors effectivement cette question de
l'irresponsabilité pénale elle date de
l'antiquité on en avait déjà parlé sur
ce plateau et donc en france
les fous ne sont pas responsables et on
ne juge pas les fous voilà c'est assez
ces grands principes mais au-delà de ça
lorsque quelqu'un est jugé irresponsable
parce qu'il a pris il a fait le choix
personnel de fumer du cannabis
là je trouve que la question de
l'irresponsabilité pénale doit être mise
en cause et moi à titre personnel je
soutiendrai une réforme avant verra dans
quelle mesure oui je soutiendrai une
réforme parce que le parlement ne peut
pas être comment ça ne peut pas être
éloignés aujourd'hui de la demande de
révision il ya un vide juridique
aujourd'hui dans notre dans notre loi et
je pense qu'il faut revoir effectivement
l'irresponsabilité pénale est très
rapidement et le mode la faisant l'aller
tout à fait d'accord mais je voudrais
juste rajouter quelque chose entre la
sphère sarah halimi et la sphère de les
tentatives d'assassinât des policiers à
viry châtillon
on voit vraiment que le gap le fossé
entre
les français et la justice s'est
aggravée parce que c'est de
l'incompréhension dont il s'agit à la
fois pour les peines qu'ils n'étaient
pas jugés par les français assez sévère
et pour l' incompréhension totale sur le
meurtre de sarah halimi et je pense
qu'il le sénat j'en suis certaine
trouvera la voie de la chasse pêche et
de la raison pour réconcilier les
français avec la justice c'est une
urgence et c'est nécessaire bien merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup à tous les deux
d'avoir participé à ce face à face
autre actualité avant de rejoindre la
séance on va faire un détour par
l'international par le proche-orient où
des dizaines de personnes ont été tuées
après une nouvelle nuit de violences
entre israël et la bande de gaza
alexandre vous êtes avec le président de
la commission de la défense et des
affaires étrangères christian cambon
mais oui christian cambon quelle est
votre réaction à cette escalade de
violence à la fois jérusalem et
maintenant ça s'étend à la bande de gaza
une double réaction la première c'est
l'inquiétude
l'inquiétude parce qu'on sait que le
conflit israélo arabe est au coeur de
tout de toute l'agitation permanente
dans cette région du monde
les événements sont gravissimes comme
d'habitude tout cela prend naissance
autour de l'esplanade des mosquées
moi je ne suis pas en mesure de dire qui
a provoqué qui met ce on peut
effectivement s'inquiéter de la tournure
des événements mon deuxième sentiment
c'est une tristesse de voir une fois de
plus l'europe qui est tout à fait
inopérantes
dans cette affaire on nous demande du
ray ce qui me quasiment même plus notre
avis enfin cesser et il pourrait faire
l'europe dans cette affaire pas déjà
elle pourrait faire entendre sa voix
mais on al'impression de latinos div
et alors qu'on a des choses à dire
puisque généralement quand il s'agit
d'agir pour la reconstruction ou pour
aider tel ou tel
c'est à l'europe c'est vers l'europe
qu'on se tourne mais là j'aimerais au
moins que l'europe fasse entendre son
message
cet après midi va y avoir une réunion à
l'onu
on espère que les puissances européennes
qui si elles autour de la salle du
conseil de sécurité vont pouvoir
s'exprimer
mais c'est une très grande inquiétude
dans un dans une région où en plus on
est déjà au bord de l'enflammer de
l'inflammation et donc on surveille
cette affaire mais on peut pas grand
chose de plus surtout que le président
le nouveau président des états unis joe
biden a l'air de rester très en retrait
de cette escalade de violence il veut
rester en retrait car finalement ce
qu'ils disent et on est en train de
sortir d'afghanistan
c'est pas pour revenir dans ce conflit
israélo palestinien qui est très
compliqué oui je comprends tout à fait
ceci posé je pense que les puissances
occidentales mais aussi la russie et
même la chine devrait faire entendre
raison aux deux parties aient montré qu'
il faut arrêter ce genre d'escapade qui
va de nouveau créé beaucoup de beaucoup
de blessures
et encore une fois la voix de l'europe
est très ténue et très faible dans cette
affaire une dernière question en
question comment sur la nouvelle tribune
des militaires qui a été publiée à cette
semaine cette fois ci des militaires
d'activé
est-ce qu'il faut les sanctionner tout
d'abord si c'est une tribune anonyme
c'est assez compliqué
moi personnellement je m'en tiens aux
droits les militaires d'activ concret il
comptera qu'une obligation de
deux distances par rapport à la vie
politique donc il faut qu'ils s'en
tiennent là et je pense qu'on a besoin
d'une armée qui soit loyale et objective
vis-à-vis de la vie politique
merci beaucoup christian combes on
pourrait se diriger dans la tribune de
presse de l'hémicycle du sénat avec vous
quand un quel est le programme cet après
midi oui alex alors que est bien géré a
marché est en train de s'installer
derrière moi dans l'hémicycle on retient
trois principaux thèmes alors d'ailleurs
les deux premières questions sont
consacrés au malaise des policiers après
et bien le meut la mort du brigadier
masson la troisième question elle
concerne les violences entre le hamas et
israël avec un un dernier bilan qui fait
état de 48 et victimes dans la bande de
gaza et le troisième thème c'est les
féminicides c'est parti pour la séance
des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement du sénat au sud
observations il y en a t'il en séance
seul envoi point le procès verbal est
adoptée sous les réserves d'usagé
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
notre séance et retransmis en direct sur
public sénat à notre site internet
chacun seront attentifs au respect des
uns et des autres et au respect du temps
de parole est immédiatement je donne la
parole à notre collègue jean baptiste
blanc pour le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole
sur le président mac ma question
s'adresse au chef du gouvernement et j'y
associe ray notre collègue alain milon
monsieur le premier ministre la
république a fait corps doit maintenant
faire face nous étions réunis hier à
avignon pour rendre un dernier hommage
au commandant éric masson un homme de
bien un homme bien comme vous l'avez
justement dit hommage lui soit encore
rendu ainsi qu'à toutes les forces de
l'ordre de notre pays qu'il faudrait
enfin apprendre à aimer la république a
fait corps autour de ce crime de trop et
je pense que tout un département vous en
remercie si ce n'est que nos concitoyens
ne supporte plus ce goutte à goutte de
criminalité qui vient maintenant jusque
dans nos campagnes mais la red river
éric masson cavaillon ma ville où a eu
lieu il ya quelques jours un règlement
de compte c'est similaire ces petites
villes et ces villages qui représente
cette provence heureuse ne veulent pas
devenir aujourd'hui la base arrière de
marseille n'accepte pas cette nouvelle
délinquance de masse ultraviolente
totalement désinhibé qui n'a peur ni de
la sanction ni de son exécution mais
pour cela maintenant il va devoir faire
face si nous ne voulons pas que 200
chasseurs vauclusiens là il se faire
justice comme ils ont exprimé ces
prémisses pour faire face nos
concitoyens ne souhaitait ni discours ni
bougies pour faire face il n'est pas
nécessaire se lancer dans un énième
concours lépine de la nouvelle loi
pénale sans cesse réécrite sous le coup
de l'émotion qui proposent souvent des
mesures déjà existantes mais rarement
appliquée car là il sans doute le
principal problème l'application des
textes et pour appliquer ces textes ne
faut pas des nouvelles procédures il
faut des moyens et les vrais il se
trouve que sur 11,2 milliards consacrés
à la police nationale moins d'un
milliard leçon pour nous son
fonctionnement et en investissement et
sur les 3 8 3 8 milliards consacrés à
notre justice ordinaire
seulement je dirais eh bien ils sont la
preuve d'une justice ans notoirement
sous capacité de jugement sans parler de
ses conditions de travail
je dirais par exemple qu'à avignon au
parc et on attend toujours des
nominations c'est très concret au plus
il y aura des moyens plus les policiers
des réponses policières et judiciaires
seront rapides et efficaces
monsieur le premier ministre entendez la
demande des territoires prenez-la au
sérieux les territoires ne peut plus
attendre
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre délégué en charge de la
citoyenneté van hamme chien tu as vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs et monsieur les
sénateurs jean baptiste blanc je veux
d'abord tout comme vous l'avez fait
m'associer à votre hommage et à votre
émotion à la suite du meurtre ignoble du
commandant éric masson auquel le premier
ministre le ministre de l'intérieur le
garde des sceaux a rendu hommage hier
chez vous en avignon et adressé bien sûr
à sa famille comme à ses collègues nos
très sincères condoléances et ignacio
est mort au cours d'une opération de
lutte contre les trafics dans un point
de lille en centre-ville avignon et en
vaucluse la lutte contre le trafic de
stupéfiants est l'une des priorités de
l'action du gouvernement
à ce titre les opérations de
sécurisation et de surveillance qui sont
régulièrement menées dans les quartiers
sensibles notamment à avignon et
carpentras ont permis la découverte
d'importantes quantités de produits
stupéfiants ainsi que d'armes à feu et
je vais vous dire que l'engagement du
ministère de l'intérieur dans cette
chute est totale et que nous y mettons
les moyens vous le savez puisque vous
avez voté le budget de la sécurité en
soulignant vous même à quel point il
était en hausse
et je tiens à vous en remercier à
nouveau la circonscription inter
départementale de sécurité publique
vaucluse gard elle doit en ce sens
pouvoir bénéficier de renforts et je
vous dis que ce sont trente et un
gardien de la paix qui sont attendus
nouveau gardien de la paix qui sont
attendus cette année
la hausse du taux d'élucidation des
affaires elle est encore plus forte avec
51% et témoigne particulièrement de la
mobilisation des services de police des
services de gendarmerie que je veux ici
saluer parce que cette mobilisation elle
ressort également de l'évolution des
infractions qui ont été relevés par
l'activité des services notamment une
hausse de près de 95% en matière de
stupéfiants entre 2020 et 2021
je souhaite exprimer au delà de
l'hommage notre gratitude vis-à-vis des
forces de l'ordre la gratitude ne suffit
pas vous avez raison mais elle est déjà
une base solide et avec la gratitude ce
sont les moyens supplémentaires pour
soutenir cette action quotidienne
des forces de l'ordre soyez assuré
monsieur sénateurs que l'ensemble du
gouvernement est mobilisé pour soutenir
nos services de police et de gendarmerie
l'engagement de l'état dans la lutte
contre l'insécurité du quotidien contre
les trafics de drogue priorité numéro un
du ministre de l'intérieur en vaucluse
comme partout ailleurs est totale pour
offrir aux français cette vie paisible à
laquelle ils ont droit
je vous remercie merci la parole est à
notre collègue loïc hervé pour le groupe
de l'union centriste
il avait la parole mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président on va
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur stéphanie mon
fermé et eric massot sont tombés sous
les coups de leur agresseur dans
l'exercice de leur métier
créant un émoi dans la nation tout
entière et le groupe de l'union
centriste veut s'associer à l'hommage
qui leur a été rendu dans les rangs de
nos forces de sécurité au sein de la
police nationale notamment après les
pleurs et la colère vient le temps des
questions
un grand malaise est perceptible c'est
vrai il y a les mots dits et ils ont été
fort monsieur le premier ministre
dans 2 éloge funèbre que vous avez
prononcé mais il ya aussi les mots qui
sont écrits ceux qui sont dans la loi et
dans la loi pénale en particulier il ya
surtout la force des décisions que nous
attendons de la justice qui doivent être
fermes dans leur prononcé comme dans la
réalité de leurs applications
plus encore que ces mots je crois que
nos policiers attendent de nous tous mes
chers collègues nous qui représentons le
peuple une protection et un soutien
encore plus fort monsieur le ministre la
loi pour une sécurité globale préservant
nos libertés va entrer en vigueur et le
beauvau de la sécurité est en cours
quelles décisions rapides entendez vous
prendre pour rendre effectif plus
rapidement encore le soutien que la
nation doit à ceux qui assurent notre
sécurité quotidienne dans vos réponses
la parole est à m
en charge de la citoyenneté vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames les sénatrices mais sur les
sénateurs je vais évidemment vous l'avez
mentionné commencé par rendre un hommage
adressé nos pensées à madame stéphanie
m'enfermer pour vous répondre sur votre
question lors de la la rencontre avec
les organisations syndicales
représentatives de la police nationale
en présence du ministre de l'intérieur
et le garde des sceaux le premier
ministre a rappelé son soutien plein et
entier aux policiers aussi l'engagement
du gouvernement
l'engagement de concrétiser la volonté
du président la république de recruter
dix mille nouveaux policiers et
gendarmes supplémentaires au cours du
quinquennat qui sera tenu pour mettre
fin à la diminution des effectifs qui
étaient enregistrés depuis une dizaine
d'années sur le plan budgétaire les
fessiers ou bénéficier d'une
augmentation de 1,7 milliard d'euros de
leurs crédits depuis 2017 dont 137
millions d'euros supplémentaires pour
l'immobilier grâce à france relance
concrètement nous venons de renouveler
25 % du parc opérationnel ça représente
8520 véhicule ce n'est pas anecdotique
ce sont les moyens qui permettent aux
forces de l'ordre de travailler et des
mesures opérationnelles inédite pour
protéger ce qui nous protège de plus des
moyens juridiques au service des forces
de sécurité intérieure sont renforcés
grâce au vote ou à la promulgation par
la majorité parlementaire de la loi de
la sécurité globale ou celle sur le
respect des principes de la république
ou la loi consacré à la lutte contre le
terrorisme
renseignements présentés en conseil des
ministres par gérald darmanin par
ailleurs banques à des travaux du bureau
de la sécurité qui ont été engagés par
le ministre de l'intérieur
la question des réponses judiciaires et
pénales fait l'objet d'une attention
toute particulière lors de la rencontre
du 27 mai prochain
enfin le premier ministre a également
annoncé mardi de nouvelles mesures
fortes plan de 10 millions d'euros pour
sécuriser les commissariats les casernes
de gendarmeries renfort des moyens de la
justice pénale face à l'engagement du
garde des sceaux car il ne peut y avoir
d'action policière efficace sans une
réponse pénale dissuasive
le premier sera annoncé vouloir inscrire
dans la loi la limitation stricte des
policiers des possibilités pardon de
réduction des peines la peine de sûreté
portées à 30 ans pour les personnes
condamnées à la
perpétuité pour un crime commis contre
un policier ou contre un gendarme
les violences contre les forces de
sécurité intérieures seront désormais
des délits spécifiques plus durement
réprimées je pense notamment la question
des refus d'obtempérer
enfin le garde des sceaux prend dans une
circulaire demandant au parquet une
fermeté strictes lorsque les forces de
l'ordre sont prises à partie en
demandant le déferrement systématique et
un jugement rapide des auteurs et je
tiens à le remercier
plusieurs mais madame la ministre je
remercie mais j'entends ce que ce que
vous dites mais c'est individuellement
que chaque policier
chaque gendarme attendu changement pour
se sentir mieux protégés 'l'annonce d'un
rassemblement le 19 20 à l'initiative
des syndicats de la police nationale
témoigne dans la paire singulière que
nous vivons d'un nouveau cris d'allah
nous sommes nombreux ici au sénat
d'avoir entendu et nous serons
certainement nombreux à soutenir toutes
les initiatives qui vont dans le sens de
la protection des forces de l'ordre elle
le mérite
la parole est maintenant président
pierre laurent pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologique
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président merci monsieur le président
mes chers collègues monsieur le ministre
des affaires étrangères nous sommes des
millions à être indigné par les images
et les témoignages qui nous parviennent
de jérusalem ratonnades expropriations
forcées de familles palestiniennes par
des colons d'extrême droite
un ultra violent et tir meurtrier de
l'armée israélienne dans l'esplanade et
dans la mosquée d'al aqsa et maintenant
bombardements de la bande de gaza il y a
déjà des dizaines de morts des centaines
de blessés
ce qui est à l'oeuvre c'est la
colonisation systématique et illégale de
jérusalem-est par le pouvoir extrémiste
de nétanyahou par une armée d'occupation
et par des colons fanatisés l'onu a
rappelé que le déplacement forcé de
civils par la puissance occupante
étaient illégales au regard du droit
international et pouvait s'apparenter je
cite à des crimes de guerre la procureur
de la cour pénale internationale parle
de fondement raisonnable
aux crimes de guerre monsieur le
ministre que fait la france
notre voie hier en première ligne s'est
éteinte au fil des eaux vous avaient
enterré la résolution du parlement pour
la reconnaissance de l'état de palestine
le résultat c'est que cette démission
internationale notre démission encourage
l'escaladé meurtrière et colonisatrice
de netanyahu
qu'attendez vous pour réagir à ses
volières violations graves et
permanentes du droit international à ces
crimes de guerre établi et répété à
réagir autrement que par des mots creux
ou part d' indigne renvoie dos à dos du
pouvoir criminel de netanyahou et des
victimes palestiniennes spoliés de leur
droit à un état
pour vous répondre la parole est à nos
yeux lui ni jean baptiste lemoyne
secrétaire d'état chargé théorie des
français de l'étranger de la
francophonie vous avez la parole merci
beaucoup monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président laurent de l'émotion c'est
bien compréhensible
nous avons tous ces images en tête mais
permettez moi de dire que l'émotion à
l'epa géométrie variable et que les
pensées nous aiderait son temps pour les
enfants qui ont pu mourir à gaza mais
également pour les civils israéliens qui
sont morts aussi mais la diplomatie à
l'oeuvre justement ce pas une diplomatie
de mosman diplomatie d'émotion elle doit
sans relâche rechercher constamment et
avec ténacité les paramètres d'une paix
durable
et de ce point de vue là nous disons les
choses très clairement oui il escalade
en cours en ce moment même elle est
préoccupante très préoccupante le
secrétaire général des nations unies
s'est exprimé ce matin même dans ces
termes là la france l'a fait également
très clairement et nous condamnons à la
fois enfin nous rappelons notre ferme
opposition à la colonisation aux
démolitions de structures palestiniennes
aux évictions dans lé quartier
palestinien de cheikh jarrah notamment à
sont illégales au regard du droit
international c'est très clair elles
sont un obstacle majeur à la paix mais
nous condamnons également très fermement
ces tirs de roquettes qui séduit encore
ont provoqué plusieurs victimes là sont
inacceptables et cela doit également
cesser immédiatement et donc toutes ces
violences
elle montre quoi elle montre la
nécessité et bien d'un processus
politique crédible et force est de
constater que chez les différentes
parties la situation politique n'est pas
stabilisée et que donc ça n'aide pas à
trouver cette solution politique mais la
france ne renoncera pas le conseil de
sécurité des nations unies se réunit à
nouveau aujourd'hui après la réunion de
lundi nous porterons d'une voix forte
cette nécessité et la france elle se
mobilise aussi avec un certain nombre de
partenaires de bonne volonté je pense à
la jordanie je pense à l'allemagne je
pense à l'egypte dans le cadre d'un
format qui était mise en place par jean
yves le drian et que nous ne cessons
lequel nous ne cessons d'avoir des
échanges et donc cela peut paraître ardu
aride mais nous ne renonçons pas à
participer à l'élaboration d'une
solution politique
monsieur le président le roch
monsieur le ministre je vous le dis
solennellement notre parole est indigne
des responsabilités de la france face à
une telle gravité
vous ne pouvez pas utiliser le dos à dos
que vous pratiquez comme une fuite en
avant de nos responsabilités ce qui est
en jeu aujourd'hui c'est jérusalem est
et vous le savez très bien
c'est ça qui est au coeur de la crise et
si vous n'agissez pas il ne se passera
rien sans sanction mais netanyahou ne
bougera pas ils s'en moquent de la loi
et du droit international vous le savez
parfaitement ils sont note même de la
justice israélien un faucon clients et
bien il faut des sanctions il faut
saisir le conseil de sécurité et il faut
suspendre l'accord d'association entre
l'union européenne et l'état d'israël et
il faut savoir vite
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
ludovic et pour le gros du rassemblement
des démocrates pro cresci chez
indépendant vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
jacqueline gourault mes chers collègues
le projet de loi cadets présenté ce
matin en conseil des ministres propose
notamment une évolution législative
concernant l'article 55 de la loi sru
bien connu sur tous les bancs de notre
assemblée
ce texte est le fruit d'un travail de
concertation que vous avez mené depuis
plus de deux ans avec les élus locaux et
les aménagements proposés par le
gouvernement à travers la saisine
rectificative vont assurément dans le
bon sens permettez moi de saluer la
ténacité dont vous avez fait preuve dans
ce dossier et la volonté forte de
convergence à pedro 2 monsieur le
président nul ne conteste la nécessité
ni la légitimité des objectifs qui ont
pu respirer c'est toi la mixité urbaine
et sociale fonctionne pour l'avoir mise
en place en tant que maire mais pas au
rythme de construction tel que demandé
actuellement le débat n'est plus de
vouloir répondre aux objectifs
arithmétique de cette loi mais de
pouvoir le faire il ne vous aura pas
échappé que les maires de france encore
faire face à un certain nombre de
contradictions sur le terrain parmi
lesquels je citerais notamment un
raisonnement en pourcentage du nombre
total de logements
ainsi tel le tonneau des danaïdes plus
vous construisez de logements et plus
vous devez en faire
la difficulté de conjuguer un impératif
de production importantes avec celui de
la moindre consommation foncière
imposé par les documents d'urbanisme une
contradiction manifeste entre les
agglomérations qui disposent de plus en
plus de compétences en matière de
logement et les exigences qui incombent
toujours directement au maire un taux de
vacance des logements insuffisamment
pris en compte sur les agglomérations
dans leur globalité des constructions
nouvelles qui se font au détriment de la
rénovation de certains logements alors
qu'il est bien souvent mieux adaptée des
infrastructures scolaires et
périscolaires qui ne sont plus adaptées
à la taille de la population
un nombre d'agréments pas toujours en
parfaite adéquation avec les demandes
des communes dont certaines voudrait
faire plus je ne voudrais pas ainsi
poursuivre cette liste mais je sais que
les échanges que vous avez eue avec les
élus locaux madame la ministre ces
derniers mois vous ont permis d'entendre
leurs craintes
madame la ministre pourriez vous nous
préciser les nouvelles dispositions du
projet de loi cadre des introduite par
la saisine rectificatif s'il vous plaît
et commandera entendez-vous poursuivre
les relations constructives avec nos
élus sur ces questions cruciales de
logements et des élus qui sont le plus à
même à faire des propositions adaptées à
notre territoire pour vous répondre la
parole est à blâmer liste de la cohésion
des territoires des relations et des
collectivités territoriales
pas d'amour au merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur ludovic
et j'ai en effet présenté ce matin au
conseil des ministres la loi à 4d qui va
marquer je crois un tournant dans les
relations entre l'état les collectivités
territoriales et je remercie le sénat
qui a lui-même hier fait une conférence
de presse monsieur le président vous y
étiez avec les deux rapporteurs
françoise gatel et mathieu darnaud et
vous avez montré votre intérêt pour
cette loi cadre et 4d je suis sûr que
nous trouverons le chemin pour
construire ce travail la différenciation
territoriales pour s'adapter aux
réalités locales
la décentralisation pour conforter les
compétences des collectivités
la déconcentration pour approcher l'état
du terrain et là des complexification
c'est à dire la simplification de
l'action publique depuis sa version
initiale le texte a été enrichi monsieur
le sénateur à travers une saisine
rectificatif qui viennent
mon répondre aux préoccupations que vous
soulignez sur le dispositif de la loi
sru
les nouvelles mesures s'appuie largement
sur le rapport du président de la
commission nationale sru thierry
repentin ancien sénateur et ont été
élaborés en concertation avec les
acteurs du logement et les collectivités
territoriales
elle prévoit d'abord une pérennisation
de la loi sru
tout le monde sait que la loi sru devait
s'arrêter en 2025 et qu'il fallait donc
anticiper pour poursuivre la
construction du logement social en
france je pense que personne n'est
contre cet objectif est naturellement
les objectifs de construction s'en
trouve lisser dans le temps
par voie de conséquence bien sûr il y a
aussi une adaptation du dispositif pour
mieux tenir compte de la capacité à
faire de chaque collectivité dans le
dialogue entre le préfet et le bloc
local
nos travaux notamment à travers les
contrats de mixité sociale
c'est l'ambition que nous portons avec
ma collègue emmanuelle wargon et pour en
avoir échangé hier avec dominique
estrosi sassone et valérie létard je
sais que c'est une ambition que le sénat
partage également parmi les points que
vous soulevez monsieur le sénateur et
dont nous avons déjà longuement
développé ce point avec les sénatrices
sachez que le régime d'exemption
notamment en matière de foncier ou de
vacances ainsi que l'intercommunale
isation des objectifs font l'objet d'un
travail continu et qui sera bien sûr
poursuivi dans le débat parlementaire
qui j'en suis sûr sera riche
je vous remercie là vous avez le temps
qui est consacré aux collectivités ou a
remarqué on rallonge de temps la parole
est à notre collègue au gel prix
pour le groupe socialiste écologique au
visage merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
actuellement des millions de personnes
dans le monde n'ont pas vraiment guéri
du coc vide entre 10 et 30% l'om est-ce
à d'ores et déjà reconnu le coc vie de
long de quoi s'agit-il
les symptômes prolonger fluctuant multi
systémique développé lors de la phase
aiguë et qui persiste essoufflement
fatigue extrême brouillard mentale
difficultés de mémoire douleurs
articulaires fourmillement perte
d'odorat troubles du sommeil
voilà parmi les nombreux symptômes
identifiés concrètement ces patients
vivent une certaine forme d'errance
médical alors qu'ils subissent un réel
handicap voire une perte d'autonomie
saviez vous qu'il est parfois nécessaire
de recourir à une rééducation
respiratoire
face à une respiration devenu
dysfonctionnel l'absence de
reconnaissance
couplée aux conséquences sociales de
perte d'emploi de vie de famille
perturbé ainsi que les incertitudes sur
les séquelles puisqu'on parle déjà de
certaines qui serait définitive sont à
l'origine d'un sentiment d'abandon que
nous devons entendre
si les recherches sont absolument
indispensable pour aboutir à des
traitements efficaces
la reconnaissance du coc vide long comme
une maladie à part entière est notre
responsabilité du moment nous avons
applaudi les soignants saluer leur
engagement louer leur dévouement
et effectivement il leur en sommes tous
tellement reconnaissants maintenant il
faut passer aux actes
car nombreux sont les soignants affectés
par ce qu vie de long leur maladie n'est
pas reconnu comme maladie
professionnelle
comment pouvons-nous les abandonner
ainsi alors qu'ils n'ont pas ménagé
leurs efforts sont montés au front sans
hésitation comme nous l'espérions
envisagez vous madame la ministre de
répondre à cette difficulté en posant le
principe d'une présomption de liens dès
lors que la maladie a été contractée par
le soignant alors qu'il était temps une
activité pendant la pandémie de façon à
ce qu'il n'y ait pas d'obstacle à la
reconnaissance légitime comme maladies
professionnelles sont merci pour vous
répondre par les calamités en charge de
brigitte bourguignon vous avez la parole
merci merci monsieur le président madame
la sénatrice angèle préville près de 10%
des patients ayant été touchés par ce
virus présentent encore plusieurs mois
après vous l'avez dit l'épisode initial
plusieurs symptômes cette persistance de
symptômes évoque un kobe blond on
distingue schématiquement des patients
présentant des complications séquellaire
de formes graves de l'aco vide
pulmonaire neurologique des autres aux
signes et symptômes généraux comme les
douleurs thoraciques
c'est fallait fatigue durable et cetera
neurosensorielle aussi perdu goût de
l'odorat qui peuvent être observés au
détour de forme initialement mineurs le
handicap est variable selon les
personnes fluctuant au cours du temps
aucun test biologique ne permet à ce
stade de l'affirmer ou de l'infirmer
c'est pourquoi il est essentiel de
reconnaître ses formes de kobe de long
c'est chose faite depuis le 14 septembre
2020 aucun retard dans l'examen des
dossiers n'est à déplorer à ce stade et
près de 25% des cas sont reconnus comme
tels
c'est en phase avec les données
épidémiologiques dont nous disposons à
ce stade les soignants les personnels
ayant travaillé dans des structures de
soins ou médico-social atteints de
formes graves respiratoire sévère de
cette maladie sont automatiquement et
systématiquement reconnu en maladie
professionnelle pour les autres cas
c'est un comité unique de reconnaissance
des maladies professionnelles
exclusivement médical qui a été mis en
place ce comité traite des personnes
souffrant de la maladie de désigner dans
le tableau mais n'en remplissent n'a pas
une ou plusieurs conditions et des
personnes qui souffrent d'une affection
non désignés mais qui présente un taux
d'incapacité permanente au moins égale à
25%
ainsi les formes graves non
respiratoires peuvent être reconnus en
revanche les formes bénignes des
pathologies ne sont pas concernés et
reste du ressort de la prise en charge
des soins et des arrêts de travail au
titre de l'assurance maladie en cas
d'évolution évidemment un nouvel examen
est possible à cette date environ 4000
dossiers complets ont été reçus par la
cnam 3200 sont déjà étudiés pour environ
800 accord maintenant pris ville
merci madame la ministre pour votre
réponse alors j'attire votre vigilance
sur le fait qu'il faut absolument
répondre à toutes les demandes qui vous
seront faites nous c'est légitime
c'est juste et nous le devons aux
soignants qui se sont engagés très
fortement jour merci
la parole est à notre collègue maryse
carrère pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
il avait la parole mes chers collègues
merci merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
déléguée en charge de l'autonomie on a
beaucoup parlé du ségur de la santé mais
nous en sommes les grands oubliés ces
propos madame la ministre ne sont pas
les miens mais ceux de virginie employés
de la maison d'accueil spécialisée à
arrens marsous ce dans les hautes
pyrénées
ils font écho à une situation qu'on
passait compenser suffisamment mises en
lumière lors de cette crise du coc vide
mais qui hélas perdure
je parle bien entendu de la non prise en
compte de la revalorisation des salaires
des soignants ne revenant ne relevant
pas de la fonction publique hospitalière
et du secteur public
leurs revendications car oui il en reste
encore des oubliés du ségur malgré les
récentes avancées et leurs erreurs leurs
revendications madame la ministre vous
les connaissez c'est d'abord la prime
qu'ovide et l'incompréhension qu'elle
crée avec des situations où selon
l'établissement avec lequel dans lequel
elle pratique une personne peut avoir
droit 183 euros supplémentaires et
d'autres non
car elles exercent dans des maisons
d'accueil spécialisées ou dans des
établissements d'accueil médicalisé
associatifs et privés
c'est aussi la question de la
revalorisation salariale d'une
profession souvent précaire car à temps
partiel est rarement rémunérés au dessus
de 900 euros
mais plus que la rémunération c'est un
statut qui est attendu et il me demande
de formation forte des personnels dans
un domaine où les crise de vocations due
aux conditions de travail ou à la
concurrence des hôpitaux viennent peu à
peu vidé ces établissements de leurs
soignants
monsieur le ministre la santé le 27
janvier dernier répondait à ma collègue
ghislaine comme tel je le cite nous
garantiront une hausse de revenus à
toute cette catégorie de personnes qui
de façon un peu aberrant effectivement
comme vous l'avez dit n'ont pas
bénéficié des revalorisations décidé
dans le cadre du ségur de la santé mais
qui travaillent eux
lui aux côtés des soignantes qui en ont
eux profité ce n'est qu'une question de
temps et se rend et ce temps sera très
court madame la sénatrice je peux vous
l'assurer c'était ses propos même si des
efforts ont été faits pour le secteur
médico social public
il reste encore des personnes qui
exercent les mêmes métiers dans les
mêmes conditions difficiles et qui reste
sur le bord du chemin
aussi ma réponse est simple quelle
réponse pouvait ma question est simple
par donc un réponse pouvez vous leur
apportez aujourd'hui pour vous répond on
attend maintenant un niveau millions
ministres changent de l'autonomie merci
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice maryse carrère durement
éprouvées durant cette crise nos
soignants ainsi que les salariés dû
prendre soin dans le médico social c'est
plus large ainsi au bénéficier d'une
reconnaissance forte après des années
d'un visibilité tout d'abord signé le 13
juillet 2020 vous le rappeler les
accords du ségur de la santé ont acté
une hausse de rémunération des
personnels des établissements
hospitaliers d'abord des établissements
d'hébergement pour personnes âgées
dépendantes les ehpad
cette augmentation de salaire et 283
euros par mois au sein des ehpad publics
et privés associatifs et 160 euros par
mois pour le secteur privé commercial
elle est intégralement pris en charge
financièrement par les pouvoirs publics
le premier ministre a demandé à michel
laforcade ancien directeur général de la
rs de nouvelles aquitaine d'ouvrir des
discussions pour étudier dans quelle
condition étendre le ségur aux autres
salariés que vous évoquez du
médico-social et elles sont en bonne
voie
par ailleurs j'ai moi même ouvert la
porte pour que les aides à domicile
intervenant chez les personnes âgées
handicapées de la branche d'ad à
domicile bénéficient quant à elles à
partir du 1er octobre 2021 d'une
augmentation salariale de 13 à 15%
ces os représente une enveloppe une
pardon de 300 millions d'euros par an à
la charge des départements
l'état prendra à sa charge 50 % du
budget annuel
70 % sur les trois derniers mois de 2010
21 hausses que nos budgets du plfss que
vous avez voté ont permises également je
précise aussi que ce sont des primes qui
seront exonérés d'impôts et de charges
sont exonérés de charges sociales et
ne seront pas imposables parce que sam a
été posé comme question enfin les
salariés du médico social ont pu tous
bénéficié d'une prime qu'ovide même
quand le financeur lé département grâce
à une aide exceptionnelle de l'état que
j'ai proposé au premier ministre qui a
accepté cet été à 80 millions d'euros
au delà de la cre activité salariale
vous avez raison le gouvernement
souhaite également modifier l'image de
ses métiers à travers une campagne de
communication
et puis tout ce qui peut tourner autour
de l'attractivité la mobilité et le bref
la revalorisation et une vraie
reconnaissance
merci la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue paul toussaint parigi pour le
groupe écologie solidarité des
territoires la parole ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
solidarités et de la santé madame le
ministre en mai 2019
votre prédécesseur agnès buzyn
promettait la prise en charge du
deuxième accompagnant de tout enfant
malade devant se déplacer sur le
continent comme prestations légales en
novembre 2019 josiane chevalier alors
préfète de la corse confirmé cette
intention en annonçant la signature d'un
décret au 1er janvier 2020
consacrant cet engagement suprême c'est
en septembre de la même année que le
président de la république confirmé à
son tour qu'une mesure entrerait en
vigueur avant la fin du mois pour
sanctuariser ce financement hors fonds
d'action sociale
deux ans que votre gouvernement a fait
naître dans le coeur des enfants malades
l'espoir de pouvoir bénéficier du droit
à être accompagnés par leurs deux
parents dans le difficile et courageux
combat qu'il mène pour la vie
deux années de promesses faites aux
associations qui vaillamment porte la
voix de la détresse de ces familles pour
mettre fin à une injustice connues et
reconnues par votre gouvernement
deux ans au cours desquels vous allez de
promesses en reculades sens aujourd'hui
sens qu'aujourd'hui une solution de
financement pérenne soit apportée en
attendant la parution de ce décret
promis maintes fois mais toujours
reporter les frais de déplacement sont
aujourd'hui pris en charge par un
dispositif d'action sociale extra-légale
temporaire des cpam et de la msa
obligeant les parents avancer les frais
de déplacement pour ce qui relève
d'autres caisses c'est la collectivité
de corse qui assure la prise en charge
un palliatif fragile dont nous pouvons
nous satisfaire à long terme
plus récemment la surprise lundi new man
sont venus mettre un terme à la tante
patiente est confiante que les familles
insulaires avaient placé en vous en
apprenant par la voie du cabinet de la
ministre gouro qu'aucun décret n'avait
été promis trahissant par là même la
parole de l'état alors monsieur le
ministre ma question sera simple et la
réponse que vous apporterez n'ira pas
aux parlementaires que je suis mais
s'adressera aux enfants malades
hospitalisés qui attendent que l'état
honore sa parole et tient ses promesses
pouvez vous nous confirmer comme vous
l'avez déjà fait le 6 octobre 2020
devant l'assemblée nationale que vous
publierez d'ici peu ce décret je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole à
madame jacqueline gourault savait pas si
les ministres distribue la parole
maintenant donc la parole comme des
bourreaux monsieur merci monsieur le bol
on savait qu'on a toutes les tendresses
pour vous merci
[Rires]
monsieur le sénateur je connais très
bien ce dossier
je connais très bien ses dossiers et je
vais préciser les choses
alors que j'étais auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur gérard collomb j'ai moi même
fait en sorte que l'association dont
vous parlez soit déclarée d'utilité
publique
c'est la première chose que je voulais
vous dire
la deuxième chose c'est que le système
de l'accompagnateur du deuxième
accompagnateurs quand un enfant malade
en corse a besoin d'aller sur le
continent pour se faire hospitaliser
puisque la réponse médicale n'est pas
sur place
elle est trop spécialisés il y avait un
accompagnement qui était simplement
l'accompagnement d'une personne nous
avons fait en sorte que l'accompagnement
de la deuxième personne c'est-à-dire du
couple en général du papa et de la maman
soit possible et aujourd'hui c'est
possible je n'ai pas les chiffres exacts
en tête monsieur le sénateur mais je
crois que c'est autour de 250 trois
enfants et familles qui ont bénéficié
aujourd'hui de ce système qui fonctionne
qui est assurée par l' agence régionale
de la santé et qui oui monsieur le
sénateur et je pourrais vous en voyez
les chiffres exacts et vous pouvez
compter sur le gouvernement pour que ce
système soit pérenne
merci
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
dan chassaing pour le groupe les
indépendants république et territoires
donner la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le président madame namyst mes
chers collègues la pandémie de kobe tu
19 entraîne des conséquences économiques
très graves
le voyons l'union européenne est en
train de mettre en oeuvre des plans de
relance pour y faire face
nous devons féliciter donc ce plan de
relance européen
d'abord parce que c'est la première fois
que l'union sans dettes au profit de ses
membres
ensuite parce que son montant de 750
milliards d'euros n'est pas négligeable
cependant nous pouvons regretter que ce
plan n'apportent aucun soutien à
l'industrie européenne de défense
il s'agit pourtant de l'un des secteur
essentiel à l'union européenne
le nombreuses menaces pèsent sur notre
continent sans industrie forte
l'autonomie stratégique peut être en
péril tout comme la sécurité de l'union
non seulement le plan de relance
européen ne prévoit rien pour cette
industrie mais il a en plus était
obtenue auprès d'une diminution du fonds
européen de défense se forme passe de 13
7 milliards d'euros pour les sept
prochaines années alors que de nombreux
états dans le monde augmente leur budget
de défense la crise de l'aco vide a
ainsi développé une autre s'ouvre
souveraineté nécessaires à mettre en
place afin que les européens prévoit
d'assurer eux-mêmes leur défense pouvez
vous nous dire madame namyst quelles
actions l'union européenne
envisage-t-elle au sujet de la défense
européenne
par ailleurs dans son budget la france
doit travailler sans attendre à
développer ses capacités stratégie mais
y at il des mesures de soutien en faveur
de l'industrie de la défense et de
l'armement prévu dans le plan de relance
français et si un deuxième plan de
relance mais en place quel en sera
détendue et est ce que des mesures sont
envisagées en faveur de cette industrie
merci pour vous répondre la parole est à
la ministre délégué en charge de la
mémoire des anciens combattants madame
geneviève darrieussecq vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice monsieur le sénateur
monsieur le sénateur chassaing bien vous
poser une question qui est importante
c'est effectivement les investissements
à venir dans la défense tant sur le plan
de notre souveraineté nationale que pour
notre souveraineté européenne
la loi de programmation militaire
française d'abord et est un plan de
relance à elle seule est la loi de
programmation militaire et respectés
dans notre pays et ne serait-ce qu'en
ce sont 22 milliards peu plus de 22
milliards de crédits d'équipement soit 1
milliard 4 de plus qu'en 2020 qui seront
consacrés donc aux équipements et
notamment aux industries de défense
je rappelle qu'en 2020 l'utilisation des
crédits non consommés en raison du coc
vide
on était tous réutilisés dans un plan de
rebond pour soutenir l'abbaye d'été et
soutenir les pme et pmi fragilisé je
rappelle aussi que il a eu des
anticipations de commandes entre dans
qui rentrait dans le cadre du plan de
soutien à l'aéronautique à hauteur de
600 millions d'euros pour le ministère
des armées donc le plan de relance
français en terme de défense est
important et au niveau européen ce n'est
pas rien 8 milliards d'euros qui ont été
voter le 29 avril
c'est une première
c'est la première fois qu'un fonds de
défense européen est votée et entre 2021
et 2027
il profitera pour un tiers pour la
recherche deux tiers pour le
développement des capacités et bien sûr
renforcera la base industrielle et
technologique de défense européenne et
assurera la souveraineté de l'union que
nous souhaitons tous bien sûr c'est un
premier pas c'est un pas important vis
milliards d'euros pour la défense qui a
été évoquée ont été votée le 29 avril
dernier je crois que nous pouvons saluer
cela et cela profitera également bien
entendu aux entreprises françaises du
domaine
mais si la parole est maintenant un
autre collègue laurence garnier pour le
groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
le 4 mai dernier
une femme est morte sous les coups de
son conjoint
il a tiré dans ses jambes avant de
l'immoler par le feu alors qu'elle était
encore en vie
cette femme s'appelait chahinez boutard
elle avait trois enfants
monsieur le premier ministre
rien rien n'a été fait pour protéger
cette femme alors que tous les voyants
étaient au rouge
son mari avait été condamné à plusieurs
reprises il possédait une arme
il était sorti de prison en décembre
2020 et sa femme avaient à nouveau porté
plainte en mars dernier malgré tout cela
madame boutin n'avait pas de téléphone
grand danger
son conjoint n'avait pas de bracelet
anti rapprochement et personne n'avait
saisi son arme
en résumé monsieur le premier ministre
toutes les mesures que vous avez prises
à la suite du grenelle sur les violences
conjugales
on était absente n'ont pas été mis en
place pour cette femme
la mission d'inspection a rendu ses
premières conclusions ce matin elle
parle d'une série de défaillances et de
dysfonctionnements on croirait entendre
une annonce de gares pour annoncer le
retard d'un train
monsieur le premier ministre
tous les meurtres de femmes ne peuvent
pas être évité celui là aurait dû l'être
si vous étiez donner les moyens
d'appliquer des lois que vous avez
vous-même voter
ma question est donc simple n'avez vous
pas honte d'une telle inefficacité de
votre politique
merci pour vous répondre
[Applaudissements]
il
la parole
la parole est à monsieur le garde des
shows
[Applaudissements]
ce qui parfois me fait honte c'est
l'exploitation c'est l'exploitation
c'est l'exploitation cynique cynique et
obscène d'une situation que nous avons
tous à déplorer avec beaucoup d'émotion
nous avons fait bien plus que vous
plus je des jo giroud le tiers-monde au
respect me répondait dans le respect
j'ai appelé tout le monde au respect au
début de la séance
vous répondez en respectant l'auteur de
la question
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas si demandé au premier
ministre si la honte c'est est
respectueux et j'entends vous répondre
sur ce registre
je redis donc que c'est nous qui après
le grenelle avons mis en place le
bracelet anti rapprochement le téléphone
grave danger l'ordonance l'ordonance
d'éloignement un certain nombre de
résultats positifs sont dès à présent à
noter mais je le dis et je les dis
d'ailleurs il n'y a pas matière bien sûr
à faire en la matière de triomphalisme
parce qu'un crime perpétré dans ces
conditions en particulier est un crime
de trop oui il y a eu un certain nombre
de dysfonctionnements
vous connaissez parfaitement le nombre
de policiers vous connaissez le nombre
de magistrats j'ai été le premier à dire
que ce bracelet anti rapprochement
madame la sénatrice ne devait pas rester
dans les tiroirs
nous avons au ministère de la justice et
monsieur le premier ministre a aucune
raison d'endosser cela distribuer les
bracelets anti-rapprochement ils sont en
nombre ils ne sont pas et ce n'est pas
de notre fait distribuer nous avons
d'emblée avec le ministre de l'ère de
l'intérieur marlène schiappa et moi même
demandé une inspection
cette inspection nous en avons pour
partie le premier rapport d'étape et
nous avons dit les uns et les autres que
nous n'aurions pas madame la sénatrice
la main qui tremble
si les dysfonctionnements sont avérés
nous n'avons pas à avoir honte d'avoir
fait ce que vous n'avez jamais fait
[Applaudissements]
la parole est
à notre collègue michel dagbert pour le
groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains avaient la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
les départements sont les chevilles
ouvrières des solidarités solidarité
territoriale mais aussi solidarité
humaine s'il revendique régulièrement
une meilleure prise en compte du reste à
charge des ayes allocations
individuelles de solidarité pour
lesquels l'adf a engagé des négociations
avec le gouvernement
ces collectivités territoriales assure
et assume pleinement leur mission comme
le rappelle à juste titre nombre de leur
président comme l'a démontré également
la crise sanitaire les départements ne
font pas de bruit mais ils font le
boulot c'est aussi le cas pour la mise à
l'abri et la protection des mineurs non
accompagnés puisque la compensation par
l'état reste conditionnée à la signature
d'une convention à em a pu à
l'évaluation de minorité par ailleurs
nous ne pouvons que déplorer ces
situations dont la presse se fait l'écho
de jeunes dont l'accompagnement 16
brutalement lorsqu'ils atteignent 18 ans
il est en effet regrettable que la
régularisation de ces jeunes qui ont
brillamment réussi leur parcours
d'insertion et d'intégration ne se fasse
souvent qu'à la faveur d'une forte
mobilisation de nos concitoyens c'est la
raison pour laquelle une proposition de
loi tendant à sécuriser l'intégration
des jeunes majeurs étrangers pris en
charge par la zone a été déposée par
jérôme durain et plusieurs de nos
collègues aussi madame la ministre
pouvez vous nous indiquer votre position
quant à la prise en charge effective par
l'état de l'accueil d'urgence de ces
jeunes ainsi que les dispositions qui
pourraient être prises à destination des
préfectures afin d'assouplir la
régularisation
lorsque l'employeur atteste de la
qualité professionnelle et de la
parfaite intégration de ces jeunes je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole de l'état
madame la ministre délégué chargé de la
citoyenneté
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur michel dagbert
d'abord vous le dit très justement la
situation des mineurs non accompagnés
elle est complexe leur nombre est en
augmentation notamment en raison de
filières de passeurs dit de faux et mais
n'a que le ministère de l'intérieur
travaillent à démanteler pour que l'état
puisse assurer la protection des mineurs
qui ont besoin et qu'ils ont le droit à
la protection de la france
l'état a donc décider d'ores et déjà de
soutenir davantage les départements un
accord a été conclu le 17 mai 2018 entre
le gouvernement et l'assemblée des
départements de france avec un volet
financier opérationnel
d'abord financement exceptionnel à
destination des départements entre 2018
et 2019
il reconduit pour 2020 un nouveau
traitement national de collecte des
données à caractère personnel la hem
l'appui à l'évaluation de la minorité
que vous connaissez qui a été mis en
place pour contribuer à l'identification
des étrangers qui se déclarent aimer n'a
enfin plusieurs actions ont été engagées
pour limiter les ruptures de droit au
passage de la majorité nous sécurisons
la phase d'évaluation de la minorité
pour que les vrais mineurs puissent
faire l'objet d'un placement à la zone
nous proposons ouais mais n'a placé à la
zone qui sont engagés dans un parcours
d'anticiper l'examen de leur droit au
séjour à la majorité pour permettre
d'effectuer sans attendre les démarches
liées aux actes d'état civil c'est la
circulaire du 21 septembre 2020 et puis
je voudrais dire que à l'occasion de son
déplacement dans le pas-de-calais en
janvier 2018 le président la république
a voulu renforcer ce dispositif par la
mise en place additionnel d'une
prestation dead alimentaires qui
représente 180 repas distribués
quotidiennement en 2021 l'état consacre
14,7 millions de crédits à la prise en
charge humanitaire soit 60 millions
depuis 2010 est enfin en ce qui concerne
l'accès à la nationalité liés au travail
je veux dire que j'ai pris une
circulaire pour faire en sorte que les
travailleurs qu'ovide de la première
ligne qui ont fait cet engagement visé
la république pendant la période de
pandémie puisse être plus rapidement
naturalisé et ce quelle que soit la
nature de leur travail et leur âge je
vous remercie
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
ami escaliers pour le groupe l'est
républicain
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
mes chers collègues ne soyez jamais les
hommes de la révolution mais les hommes
du gouvernement et fait que la france
date son bonheur de l'établissement des
préfectures
ces mots sont ceux de napoléon bonaparte
au nouveau préfet napoléon 1er dont le
président de la république commémorer le
5 mai dernier le bicentenaire de sa mort
deux cents ans plus tard nous saluons
toujours la création des préfectures
premier pas vers la déconcentration
pourtant des lendemains de cette
commémoration vous annonciez monsieur le
premier ministre devant l'ensemble des
préfets et sous-préfets la fin de ce
corps d'état cette fonctionnalité sion
des préfets est incompréhensible
elle est incompréhensible car elle
déconstruit l'état et son autorité une
autorité plus que jamais essentielle en
ces temps troublés par l'insécurité la
violence et les différentes crises que
nous subissons elle est incompréhensible
car elle rompt le lien de proximité
entre l'état et les territoires une
proximité qui est la clé de voûte de
l'action de l'état déconcentré une
efficacité démontrée par le couple
préfet maire depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire représentant de l'état dans
les territoires les préfet ne sont pas
de simples administrateurs ils sont le
lien entre l'état et des élus locaux
préfet est un métier on le devient grâce
à ce corps la loi cadets tardive et
timide devra s'appuyer sur ce corps
bicentenaire pour construire une
nouvelle génération de décentralisation
car ce sont des concentrations il n'y
aura ni différenciation ni des
complexification et encore moins de
décentralisation alors monsieur le
premier ministre voulait vous nous
affirmer ici au sénat que le corps
préfectoral ne disparaîtra pas
pouvez-vous nous assurer que cette
réforme n'ouvre pas la porte de
l'arbitraire dans la fonction publique
pour vous répondre à paroles et comme
monsieur le premier ministre
mais la parole monsieur 1er mai merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
je voudrais d'emblée vous dire que vous
avez devant vous le premier ministre qui
a promu le couple maire préfet vous a
bien vu vous a bien voulu le rappeler
dans votre intervention à la faveur du
premier déconfinement vous avez
également sachez le un premier ministre
qui a eu l'immense honneur d'être
secrétaire général de préfecture et
sous-préfet d'arrondissement chef lieu
dans sa vie professionnelle
un vrai bonheur et je voudrais dire au
sénat derrière votre question combien je
m'associe à vos propos rendant hommage à
l'administration préfectorale au sous
préfet aux préfets partout en france
depuis napoléon sans doute dans les
temps actuels surtout au service de la
république au service la crise matin
midi et soir la nuit sept jours sur sept
et dans des conditions parfois
extrêmement difficile dois je rappeler à
la haute assemblée que j'ai remis avec
les directeurs généraux des agences
régionales de santé les préfets au coeur
d'un gestion de nos crises sanitaires et
vous l'avez constaté dans vos
départements
alors je vous rappeler que c'est mon
gouvernement qui a placé les préfets aux
avant postes d'un des axes essentiels la
politique de l'état pour le pays
la relance j'ai même avec la ministre la
transformation et de la fonction
publique
créer des nouveaux postes de sous
préfère la relance alors je voudrais
affirmer très solennellement ici devant
vous comme je lé fais
d'ailleurs il y a quelques jours devant
l'ensemble des préfets sous préfets que
j'ai réunis par visioconférence
évidemment crise sanitaire oblige que la
réforme la réforme indispensable de la
haute fonction publique en général que
nous conduisons loin de vouloir porter
atteinte à ces éminentes assez
indispensable fonction vise au contraire
non seulement à les conforter
mais encore anne accroître
l'attractivité et finalement vous
l'avais un peu dit dans votre question
ce que nous cherchons à valoriser au
maximum c'est le métier c'est la filière
préfectorale
c'est ce métier qu'il faut à tout prix
conforter et croyez moi si ça passait
par des corps ou des statuts il ya
longtemps que ça se saurait ce n'est pas
là la marque d'une gestion des
ressources humaines modernes et
dynamiques
nous allons revalorisé nous allons
revaloriser ce beau métier ce métier
indispensable vous l'avez dit confère la
réponse de l'amour tout à l'heure en
relançant la déconcentration
j'ai déjà pris une circulaire
extrêmement importante pour renforcer
leurs prérogatives en matière de
ressources humaines et de gestion
budgétaire en déconcentrant des crédits
depuis paris dans la loi de finances
pour 2021 qui a été examiné dans cette
assemblée
l'essentiel des effectifs nets de l'état
hors éducation nationale ont été créés
dans les échelons déconcentrés de l'état
nous allons donc évidemment créer une
filière une filière de la préfectorale
car elle suppose expérience par
engrenage compétences spécifiques
ce n'est pas parce que nous allons
fidèles à l'ordonnancé 1945 redonner
toute sa place à l'interministérialité
la haute fonction publique que nous
allons ce sera même le contraire nier la
spécificité du métier préfectoral nous
allons le renforcer nous allons la
restaurer encore davantage dans cette et
ce sera mon dernier mot dans cette
réforme il ya un objectif y en a bien
d'autres
mais qui me tiennent particulièrement à
coeur au delà de l'administration
préfectorale
c'est tout l'état déconcentré qui est
trop éclatée trop diluer trop diluée et
que nous devons rassembler autour de
l'autorité préfectorale
sachez sachez mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs qu'aujourd'hui hors éducation
nationale 85 % 85% des fonctionnaires de
la république tous confondus sont dans
les territoires 92% des hauts
fonctionnaires sont à paris ça ne peut
pas marcher durablement comme ça et donc
désormais à la future y nsp successeur
de l'ena tous les élèves qui sortiront
tous seront affectés dans leur premier
poste sur des fonctions opérationnelles
aucun ne rejoindra plus des fonctions de
contrôle des grands corps de l'état ou
des fonctions juridictionnelles priorité
au terrain et l'administration
préfectorale
je vous le dis sera restaurée dans son
prestige il est déjà immense mais
renforcé dans ses attributions et dans
le beau métier qu'elle représente
mais le refus
la parole était le pru au pardon madame
caennaise et moi merci monsieur le
ministre vous affirme effectivement
vouloir renforcer et moderniser les
préfets etc cela nous sommes d'accord
mais tout en substituant une fonction
publique loyal à une fonction publique
inféodé en touchant aux piliers de
l'état vous risquez de fragiliser tout
l'édifice de l'état 79% des élus locaux
plébiscitent les préfectures vote
réforme va pour nous à contresens
si la parole est à notre collègue
jean-marie misons pour le groupe de
l'union centriste
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre jacqueline gourault elle
porte sur la rénovation de la voirie
municipale
madame la ministre vous qui avait été
maire durant des décennies
vous savez mieux que beaucoup que les
travaux de rénovation de la voirie sont
une constante dans la vie municipale
mais aujourd'hui nombre de communes
n'ont plus les moyens de financer ces
travaux
deux raisons essentielles à cela d'une
part le département et la région qui
traditionnellement aider le plus les
communes a effectué ces travaux se sont
appauvris
d'autre part l'état lui-même a
puissamment réorienter ses priorités
avec le plan de relance et la transition
écologique
ce faisant on a mis la voirie municipale
et sa sécurisation de côté comme s'il
s'agissait d'une sous dépenses une
dépense d'un autre temps en marge du
progrès cet absurde car il ne peut y
avoir de relance ni de transition
énergétique sans voirie municipale
pas de voitures électriques ou à
hydrogène sans route à emprunter pas de
plan vélo sont réguliers requalification
des voix elle en parle là du simple
entretien qui renaît on ne parle pas là
du simple entretien qui ré de la dépense
de fonctionnement mais vraiment de la
rénovation qui relève d'investissement
ma question est donc simple madame la
ministre le gouvernement envisage-t-il
de délais de dédier une enveloppe à ces
travaux de voirie municipaux pour vous
répondre
la parole est à la milice de la cohésion
des territoires et des relations avec le
parlement
avec les collectivités territoriales
mais le parlement aussi à les distribuer
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur d'abord je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous sur ce que vous avez
déclaré sur l'avenir de la voiture
électrique à hydrogène et la nécessité
d'entretenir les routes on est d'accord
deuxièmement je sais combien il est
parfois difficile pour des petites
communes de disposer des crédits pour à
la fois les travaux de fonctionnement
d'investissement vous avez bien rappeler
et pour l'ingéniérie aussi mais vous
savez quand même que l'intercommunalité
a aujourd'hui apporter des réponses
aussi bien en un générique en travaux je
rappelle qu aujourd'hui 75% des
communautés de communes ont fait valoir
l'intérêt communautaire auquel je suis
particulièrement moi attaché et 85%
aussi des communautés d'agglomération
donc il y a des solutions il y a aussi
des solutions que l'état apporte je vous
rappelle que les financements classiques
de dut airs et deux des six peuvent
salle et sur la voirie bien entendu et
si si si ils peuvent aller sur la voirie
et nous avons eu un milliard
supplémentaire avec le plan de relance
si vous dites non c'est peut-être parce
que la commission départementale a
décidé de ne pas le faire mais
émotionnel fonctionnement puisque ça
fait longtemps que je suis maire comme
le vous l'avez rappelé mais c'est
possible bien donc il y à des
financements classiques + 1 millions du
plan de relance 1 milliard pardon du
plan de relance de décines plus je
rappelle aussi
215 millions qui sont sortis du plan de
relance pour les pistes cyclables qui
peuvent accompagner les voiries
communales par ailleurs action coeur de
ville petite ville de demain sont aussi
des financements possibles pour la
voirie communale et pour bénéficier de
l'appui de l'état sur les réaménagement
des espaces publics
je voudrais rappeler aussi puisque vous
avez parlé des départements et des
régions qui sont appauvris pour des
longs certaines régions je voudrais
insister aussi sur les choix politiques
parfois qui sont faits par les régions
de ne pas subventionner la voirie je le
tiens à le faux couple on est fort je
conclure en vous disons que
naturellement nous sommes là aussi pour
l'ingénierie bien je donne monsieur
misons vous avez tous allez-y j'ai donc
madame la ministre
une réponse convaincante n'est pas vrai
pour autant les seulement convaincante
c'est déjà pas mal mais voyez vous la
vérité c'est que depuis trop d'années
maintenant les six communes les
collectivités sont siphonnées de toutes
parts après des années de baisse
drastique de la dgf cdgf stagne à son
niveau le plus bas depuis 2010 est ce
qui entraîne des pertes lourdes cumulées
pour nombre de communes avec la
suppression de la progressive de la taxe
d'habitation est à présent des impôts
locaux de production qui vient d'achever
la miss la disparition du pouvoir fiscal
des collectivités et la mise sous
tutelle financière des communes ce qui
s'est d'ailleurs une marque de fabrique
de ce quinquennat ça fait encore des
recettes de moi et si j'ajoute à cela
les refus de votre gouvernement de
compenser les pertes de recettes
tarifaires
les nouvelles dépenses auxquelles
doivent faire face les communes en
particulier pour faire face précisément
la crise on comprend très bien que la
situation qui est la leur mais n'est pas
telle qu'elle puisse financer sans être
complémentaires des travaux de voirie c
opportunité que je vous proposais de
saisir et madame claire c'est vous qui
voyez parents les cas notre collègue
bernard bonne pour le groupe l'est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame frédéric vidal les
universités de médecine ont annoncé que
pour l'année 2020 2021
le numerus à perthus avait augmenter
très sensiblement par rapport au numerus
clausus c'est une excellente décision
que nous attendions tous avec de
surcroît un engagement sur cinq ans
permettez-moi tout de même de vous
signaler que cette évolution est très
disparate selon les territoires 30% à
paris 14% à lyon 7 % à saint-etienne il
faudra nous expliquer la loi de la
ministre cette inégalité de traitement
mais je voudrais surtout vous
interpeller sur la situation des
étudiants inscrits en passe très
pénalisées en cette année de transition
par la réforme des études de santé
pour mémoire les passes des premières
années les primes en 2019 2020
on tue un taux de réussite moyen de 12%
une possibilité de repasser le concours
cette année avec un taux de réussite
moyen de 40 % mais les passes de cette
année n'auront que le même taux de
réussite de 12% car l'augmentation des
places est pratiquement totalement
dévolue aulas c'est à dire aux étudiants
inscrits en licence dans d'autres
filières de santé
de plus ces mêmes primes ans ne pourront
pas redoublé dans les mêmes conditions
par contre ceux qui vont s'inscrire en
2021 2022 retrouveront eux les places
réservées jusqu'à lors ou double en et
auront des chances de réussite d'environ
30%
d'après des calculs des universités
quelle injustice madame la ministre pour
les étudiants passent de première année
de médecine
imaginez leur déception d'être dans
cette année de transition
si défavorable sans augmentation du
nombre d'admis et après avoir subi une
année si difficile en raison du
confinement
madame la ministre je vous le demande au
nom de tous ces étudiants de grande
qualité pour la plupart augmenté pour
cette année exceptionnelle de transition
le nombre de places pour les passes nous
avons besoin de ces médecins dans tous
nos territoires
je vous remercie
on vous répondra par la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
d'innovation d'un vidal vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
dessinatrice messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur sénateur vous avez raison de
rappeler que cette fois ma santé 2022 va
profondément transformer les choses
d'abord parce que on va diversifier non
seulement les profils des étudiants mais
les voies d'accès ensuite parce que les
étudiants pourront démarrer et puis dans
le cadre des réformes du deuxième et du
troisième cycle poursuivre aussi leurs
études partout sur le territoire et que
c'est comme ça que l'on luttera vraiment
contre la désertification médicale
et puis enfin parce que pour la première
fois depuis plus de 50 ans nous aurons
cette année plus de dix mille six cents
jeunes qui accéderont en deuxième année
des études de médecine ça n'était jamais
arrivé
c'est une augmentation de 14% et c'est
une augmentation évidemment qui confirme
les engagements que nous avons pris
je tiens à dire aussi que il n'y a
aucune perte de chance pour les
étudiants cette année puisque l'ensemble
des places qui ont été ajoutées ont été
réservés non pas aulas comme il dit mais
à tous les primes en les passes comme
les las alors je voudrais peut-être
prendre quelques chiffres de manière à
être extrêmement clair et je vais
prendre par exemple les chiffres de
saint-etienne puisque vous mentionnez
cette université il y aura pour la
rentrée 2021 264 places dans les
filières santé en deuxième année
c'est l'ensemble des filières médecine
médiatique dentaire et odontologie
bonotto logis voilà il y aura 185 places
pour les étudiants
qui accéderont en deuxième année de
médecine il y en avait cent soixante dix
l'année dernière sur ses 264 places qui
sont réservés en 2e année pour toute
étude de santé et bien il y à 121 une
place qui sont pour les redoublants et
100 places qui sont pour les passes
c'est à dire que sur les 264 places 100
places ont pour les passes jamais
déprimant n'ont eu autant de chance
d'accéder en deuxième année des études
de santé que cette année je crois que
c'est très important de préciser enfin
sûrs de préciser enfin que bien sûr tous
les étudiants auront une deuxième chance
mais l'auront en progressant à l'heure
et ils n'ont pas en redoublant qu'un an
avant
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
puis surnom sarrazy pour le groupe
socialiste écologique et républicaine
la parole merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'économie et des finances et j'y
associe notre collègue de jean claude
tissot sénateur de la loire
monsieur le ministre les fédérations des
entreprises de l'artisanat et du
bâtiment nous ont alertés sur la pénurie
de matériaux et la flambée des prix qui
les impacts en dépit de leur
mobilisation auprès des pouvoirs publics
ces derniers mois rien ne le semble
avoir été fait pour anticiper cette
situation elles connaissent en effet les
plus grandes difficultés à
s'approvisionner en bois dérivés de bois
polyuréthane polystyrène plaques de
plâtre pour ne citer que quelques
exemples
le prix de l'acier du pvc ont augmenté
respectivement de 106 et 114 % celui du
cuivre de 51%
tout le paradoxe est là alors que les
demandes des particuliers la commande
publique en matière de construction sont
en hausse
les entreprises risquent de ne pas
pouvoir les satisfaire faute
d'approvisionnement correct c'est
pénurie entraîne déjà l'arrêt de
certains chantiers et vont certainement
impacté en conséquence de nombreux corps
de métiers et ce dans un contexte de
relance économique et de préservation
impératif de l'emploi bien que la crise
sanitaire ne soit pas étrangère à ces
difficultés celle ci était cependant
prévisible
puisque nous ne maîtrisons plus les
chaînes d'approvisionnement de matières
premières ou de produits semi
transformés dans de nombreux secteurs le
cas du bois est révélateur depuis
plusieurs années les grumes française le
chêne en particulier sont massivement
exportée vers l'asie et la chine a un
prix supérieur de 25 à 30% à ce que les
scieries françaises sont en mesure de
proposer pour être ensuite importé si la
chine ne veut bien une fois transformé
les professionnels de la filière bois
ont pourtant maintes fois alerté sur le
manque croissante de matières premières
pour les transformateurs locaux sans
être pour autant entendu aujourd'hui
nous en voyons le résultat c'est tout le
tissu manufacturier français qui est
menacée cette situation interroge
fortement une fois de plus notre
souveraineté industrielle
monsieur le ministre que comptez vous
faire pour garantir cette autonomie
nécessaires au bon fonctionnement de
notre industrie
si l'avenir nous réserve de nouveaux
épisodes de crise quelle que soit leur
nature pour vous répondre la parole et
communistes de l'est en charge des
conflits que sur youtube merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur dans sa
radio je partage beaucoup de votre
question et le gouvernement partage les
préoccupations qui sont les vôtres la
reprise économique extrêmement rapide en
asie et la reprise mondiale d'une
certaine manière amène des difficultés
des tensions sur le prix des matières
premières vous avez cité un certain
nombre d'exemples et des difficultés
d'approvisionnement nous pourrions
ajouter l'augmentation du prix du baril
de pétrole qui se traduit à la fois par
une augmentation des prix de revient
pour les secteurs énergivores mais aussi
par une augmentation du prix production
des matières plastiques avec les
difficultés identiques à celles que vous
avez évoquées nous apportons de type de
réponse une réponse de court terme qui
consiste d'abord à assurer un suivi
extrêmement précis c'est le papa secteur
de ses difficultés mais aussi à
fluidifier et les transports et les
échanges en activant un certain nombre
de mesures douanières en travaillant sur
par des actions diplomatiques auprès des
pays concernés
en réunissant 6 les filières pour les
inciter à partager à mutualiser un
certain nombre de moyens mais aussi à
dissuader les plus grands donneurs
d'ordres de constituer des stocks de
précaution qui manqueraient à de plus
petits acheteurs nous nous veillons
aussi à ce que dans le respect de leurs
prérogatives évidemment les acheteurs
publics puissent faire preuve de
bienveillance en matière de difficultés
sur les chantiers mais au-delà de ces
réponses à court terme ne devons
travailler à plus long terme c'est
l'objet absolument premier du plan de
relance et des mesures de résilience
nous étions ensemble avec bruno le maire
dans notre département il ya quelques
jours pour accompagner un projet de
production en matière de matériels
médicaux
vous avez évoqué la filière bois et vous
savez je crois que nous consacrons
beaucoup à la relocalisation
d'ores et déjà ce sont plus de 273
projets qui sont financés par l'état
pour de la réalisation et notamment de
la reconquête de souveraineté
industrielle 273 projets accompagnés
pour un total de 462 millions d'euros
mais surtout un total d'investissement
d'un milliard 800 millions d'euros et un
projet de création de 25000 emplois au
total
derrière ces emplois et ses
investissements c'est la reconquête de
la souveraineté c'est la reconstitution
des chaînes de valeur et c'est faire en
sorte qu'à l'avenir nous ne soyons plus
dépendant d'autres pays où d'autres
continents pour les matières premières
vous avez évoqué merci ma parole et à
d'autres collègues le président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse
madame la ministre de la culture ni vous
ni nous personne ici ne veut d'un
deuxième était son festival
or nous sommes tous conscients que nous
pourrons réorganiser les festivals
pendant l'été qu'à la condition de
pouvoir les préparer en amont avec toute
la kyrielle de mesures qui devront
s'imposer à juste titre petit à petit
vous desserrer l'étau vous lever
certaines contraintes
mais globalement les festivaliers sont
face à trop d'inconnues alors que les
dates se rapprochent dansait déjà dans
les ardennes le festival du cabaret vert
a dû être supprimés et réadapter au
contexte un festival ce n'est pas une
séance de cinéma un festival doit cela
cela sont programmés longtemps à
l'avancé pour réserver les spectacles
les artistes or si les choses restent
trop floue pour les organisateurs qui
seront obligés de supprimer leurs
manifestations
au mois de septembre dans les ardennes
nous avons le festival international des
théâtres de marionnettes et les
organisateurs sont très inquiet car
certains festivals sont pros
mais plus tard dans l'été ce qui va
provoquer une concentration des
événements culturels et la mutualisation
habituel du matériel va être mise à mal
du fait du resserrement des dates des
festivals la question du pass sanitaire
illustre tout à fait le questionnement
que je formule devant vous aujourd'hui
comment organiser efficacement les
contrôles comment organiser la jauge des
quatre mètres carrés par personne
comment être le plus juste et le plus
adapté possible à toutes les situations
comment encadrer la circulation des
foules comment soit réglé la question
des buvettes les festivaliers ont besoin
de connaître l'état de réflexion du
ministère sur d'autres problématiques
liées à la copie de l'état
d'impréparation du gouvernement n'a pas
rendu service aux objectifs poursuivis
et je compte bien sur vous pour nous
éclaircir sur le sujet culturel madame
la ministre je pense j'espère que vous
allez être meilleur que les autres
ma question est simple quelles garanties
qu'on me donnait le gouvernement pour
les festivals de l'été pour vous
répondre
madame la ministre bachelot j'avais la
parole monsieur le président mesdames
les sénatrices monsieur les sénateurs
pendant la sénatrice et dit joseph je
partage avec vous la conviction que nos
festivals sont un élément structurant de
l'animation des territoires et j'ai fait
tout pour les préserver pour les aider
dans leur programmation dans
l'établissement de règles sanitaires les
plus favorables possibles
vous connaissez le calendrier il ya des
festivals très différents entre un
festival de musique baroque dans une
église romane est un festival de musique
électro qui peut regrouper vingt mille
personnes
il est difficile d'établir des règles
communes vous les connaissez
néanmois 35% de jauge autorisait à
partir du 19 mai dans la limite de huit
cents personnes à l'intérieur et 2000
personnes à l'extérieur à partir de 9
jeux
du 9 juin jauge à 65% avec 5000
personnes de plafond maximum et à partir
du 1er juillet il y a deux types
d'établissements évidemment de festivals
les festivals ah sinon vous connaissez
là aussi les normes que nous adoptons et
puis se pose la question des festivals
debout que vous avez évoquées bien
entendu tout cela sera en train est en
train d'être précisée nous avons à la
demande des professionnels certains
professionnels adopté l'ajout de quatre
mètres carrés tout par festivaliers tout
ça demeure à être précisée des réunions
de travail sont prescrites dans les tout
prochains jours pour adapter les
modalités de la même façon sur le pass
sanitaires les choses seront simplifiées
au maximum avec les lecteur de qr code
et nous envisageons de connecter les
billetteries avec ce qr codes du passani
terre donc les choses seront simplifiées
et je tiens à préciser que bien entendu
la restauration les bars qui sont si
importants pour l'économie de nos
festivals seront autorisés comme la
restauration classique
en tout cas j'ai bien l'intention de me
rendre au festival cabaret vert et au
festival international de marionnettes
et j'espère que nous aurons le plaisir
de nous y retrouver madame la sénatrice
merci madame la ministre les vaccins
vous avez montré par le passé que vous
savez faire et bien montrez nous ce que
vous savez faire maintenant pour les
festivals et le temps presse vous l'avez
dit donc un certain nombre de choses
doivent être annoncés et c'est avec un
grand plaisir qu'on vous accueillera
dans les ardennes
la parole est un autre collègue olivier
cadic pour le groupe de l'union
centriste dans le féminisme et chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre en charge des
français de l'étranger
le 29 mai en a mais en amérique et le 30
mai dans le reste du monde se tiendront
les élections consulaires pour élire les
conseillers des français de l'étranger
et les délégués consulaires les
électeurs à l'étranger auront également
la possibilité de voter par internet du
21 au 25 mai
c'est heureux et compte tenu des
conditions sanitaires j'encourage tous
nos compatriotes à l'étranger à choisir
ce mode de vote pour s'exprimer il y a
deux jours nous avons appris par le
bulletin quotidien le dépôt à
l'assemblée nationale d'un amendement du
gouvernement au projet de loi relatif à
la gestion de la crise sanitaire rendant
possible dans les circonscriptions où le
sculpteur scrutin poserait une
difficulté
le report des élections consulaires
compte tenu des circonstances
rencontrées dans certains pays on peut
comprendre que le vote à l'urne puis
c'est difficile voire impossible
à titre d'exemple en malaisie le premier
ministre malaisien a annoncé lundi soir
l'extension des mesures de confinement
strict à l'ensemble du territoire
jusqu'au 7 juin inclus
la situation est particulièrement
alarmante en inde suite à la parution de
l'article dans le bulletin quotidien
le on dit s'est très vite propagé et a
pu altérer la sérénité de la campagne
dans plusieurs endroits dans le courrier
que vous nous avez adressé aux
parlementaires hier
monsieur le ministre nous n'avons aucun
indice sur l'étendue des
circonscriptions potentiellement
affectés par cette perspective
un autre jour de l'ouverture du scrutin
par internet dix-sept ou dix-huit jours
du vote à l'urne
je souhaite lutter contre les fausses
nouvelles et mobiliser les électeurs à
l'étranger pour les inciter à participer
aux élections consulaires
pouvez vous nous indiquer quelle est la
liste des circonscriptions concernées
par un report éventuel afin de clarifier
la situation
alors que nous nous engageons dans la
dernière ligne droite à défaut nous
souhaitons savoir combien de
circonscriptions sont susceptibles
d'être affectées et la date à laquelle
elles seront connues
je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole et au
secrétaire d'état en charge des français
de l'étranger monsieur le one vous avez
la parole merci beaucoup monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur olivier
cadic permettez moi au début de cette
réponse déjà de rendre hommage à monique
cerisier ben guiga sénatrice
représentant les français établis hors
de france qui nous a quittés il y a
quelques jours elle a été une
personnalité éminente qui a promu les
dispositifs l'âme notamment et je tenais
aujourd'hui à l'évoquer devant vous
s'agissant de l'organisation de ce
scrutin très important les élections qui
vont permettre de désigner les
conseillers des français à l'étranger
les élus locaux finalement représentant
les français établis hors de france
comme toute élection c'est un défi
logistique et ça l'est d'autant plus
dans un contexte épidémique qui continue
à sévir dans le monde et c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs je rends hommage à toutes
celles et tous ceux qui à la fois au
sein des ambassades et consulats les
élus les assesseurs
mais également en centrale et bien sont
à la tâche pour que ces élections se
passent dans les meilleures conditions
avec les modalités à l'urne 80% des
bureaux de vote ont été maintenus par
rapport au précédent scrutin je crois
que ça mérite d'être soulignée dans le
contexte que nous connaissons
alors le gouvernement il fait tout
simplement ce qu'il a dit qu'il ferait
lorsque nous avons rendu un rapport au
parlement et donc au sénat le 18 février
dernier
nous indiquions très précisément que
pour que le scrutin se tienne dans de
bonnes conditions
il fallait prévoir et anticiper aussi
les mesures transitoires au cas où dans
certaines circonscriptions le vote ne
puisse pas se tenir puisque
effectivement nous ne pouvons pas
maîtriser les conditions sanitaires leur
évolution nous ne pouvons pas maîtriser
les décisions souveraines des états dans
lesquels se tiennent ces scrutins des
décisions de confinement des décisions
restreignant la mobilité est ce que je
peux vous dire
j'ai en tête par exemple le cas de
l'inde que vous évoquiez c'est que notre
souhait c'est que on puisse tenir le
scrutin
naturellement partout idéalement et
sinon si des mesures doivent être prises
c'est en dernière extrémité est
naturellement cela se fait en
concertation avec les conseils des
français à l'étranger j'ai instruit les
postes pour que il travaille lorsque il
y à une interrogation qui se pose avec
les élus donc des conseils consulaires
et j'entends bien que ce rendez vous
pour un million de français établis hors
de france se tiennent dans meilleures
conditions nous mêmes nous allons
également politiquement porter le sujet
là où d etat aurait des réticences à
permettre la tenue du scrutin
donc nous sommes en milieu de semaine
prochaine nous serons en mesure de vous
indiquer cette liste merci monsieur k
dick
je remercie monsieur le ministre pour
votre réponse et je comprends que vous
devez faire preuve de pragmatisme pour
nous confronter à cette situation
l'examen au sénat de l'amendement adopté
hier par les députés permettra de
clarifier le dispositif légal pour les
élections à l'assemblée des français de
l'étranger
en tenant compte de la position de
l'assemblée des français de l'étranger
et je veux le dire de notre expérience
merci merci monsieur le premier ministre
eut des messieurs les ministres ont
terminé avec les questions au
gouvernement
je vous remercie je vous rappelle que
les prochaines questions d'actualité
auront lieu mercredi 19 mai je vais
suspendre la séance
elles soient reprises à 16h35 pour la
suite du projet de loi de programmation
relatif au développement solidaire et à
la lutte contre les inégalités mondiales
d'un séance est suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance de questions au
gouvernement que vous avez pu suivre en
direct et en intégralité sur public
sénat on va tout de suite rejoindre
quentin qu'elle met dans l'hémicycle du
sénat qu'avez vous retenu de cette
séance quand on est bien on retient ce
moment de grande tension dans
l'hémicycle il serait que ces moments de
tension sont rares et ils sont d'autant
plus impressionnants ici à la chambre
haute
tout est parti d'une question de la
sénatrice et l'air laurence garnier
suite au meurtre d'une jeune femme
chahinez la semaine dernière elle a dit
rien n'a été fait pour protéger cette
femme car elle n'avait pas de téléphone
grand danger le conjoint n'avait pas de
bracelet anti rapprochement des mesures
permise par la loi
écoutez la suite de la question et avec
ces mots qui ont beaucoup déplu au garde
des sceaux
la mission d'inspection a rendu ses
premières conclusions ce matin elle
parle d'une série de défaillances et de
dysfonctionnements on croirait entendre
une annonce de gares pour annoncer le
retard d'un train
monsieur le premier ministre
tous les meurtres de femmes ne peuvent
pas être évité celui là aurait dû l'être
si vous vous étiez donner les moyens
d'appliquer des lois que vous avez
vous-même voter ma question est donc
simple
n'avez vous pas honte d'une telle
inefficacité de votre politique à ce
moment là la question a été posée dans
un grand silence dans l'hémicycle a même
été ensuite applaudi y compris sur les
bancs de la gauche
ici au sénat et donc c'est le garde des
sceaux eric dupond-moretti qu est bien
tenté de répondre il n'a pas pu
prononcer beaucoup de mots écoutez ce
qui parfois me fait honte c'est
l'exploitation
c'est l'exploitation c'est
l'exploitation cynique cynique et
obscène d'une situation que nous avons
tous à déplorer avec beaucoup d'émotion
nous avons fait bien plus que vous
plus jeune j'ai entièrement non respect
on répondait dans le respect j'ai appelé
tout le monde au respect au début de la
séance
vous répondez en respectant l'auteur de
la question
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas si demandé au premier
ministre si la honte c'est est
respectueux et j'entends vous répondre
sur ce registre
voilà le début de la réponse en garde
des sceaux qu'on arrivait à peine à
entendre ici en tribune de presse tant
le broc a été fort avec ses sénateurs de
la droite comme de la gauche qui tapait
sur leurs tablettes pendant la réponse
d'eric dupond-moretti
voilà un moment d'extrême tension qui a
donc marqué cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement et pour
revenir sur ce moment et les ans va
justement rejoindre alexandre poussin
vous êtes avec l'une des protagonistes
de cet échange vous êtes avec la
sénatrice laurence garnier
mais oui laurence garnier bonjour qu'est
ce que vous avez pensé de cette réaction
du ministre de la justice qui estime que
vous avez fait je cite une exploitation
cynique du drame de mérignac
si le premier ministre et son
gouvernement et monsieur dupont moretti
estime que regarder la réalité en face
regardez ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
dans notre pays en matière de violence
conjugale
s'il estime que dire les choses c'est de
la récupération c'est de l'exploitation
politique
eh bien écoutez je ne peux que le
regretter et je pense que
malheureusement on alimente ce système
ont fait beaucoup de tort à la
démocratie en refusant de regarder la
réalité des choses
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous reprochez
au gouvernement dans cette affaire
un rapport d'inspection en tout cas le
rapport d'étape de la mission
d'inspection autour de cette affaire a
été rendu ils signalent des
dysfonctionnements notamment des
services et le gouvernement a dit les
dysfonctionnements maintenant on va
prendre des sanctions qu'elle quel est
le souci
c'est très clair en réalité il ya eu il
ya quelques mois un grenelle des
violences conjugales qui date maintenant
d'ailleurs déjà 18 mois qui a permis de
mettre en oeuvre un certain nombre de
dispositifs pour protéger les femmes
victimes de violences confiscation de
larmes de leurs conjoints mise en place
de bracelets anti-rapprochement pour ces
hommes violents et mise à disposition
pour les femmes victimes de violence de
téléphone grave danger tout ça c'est
dans la loi c'est dans la loi
celle qui a été proposée puis votée par
le député aurélien pradié puis par la
loi qui a fait suite à ce grenelle des
violences conjugales en juillet 2020
aucune de ces mesures qui est pourtant
dans la loi n'a été mise en place pour
protéger chahinez doute à ce que je
reproche très clairement c'est que le
gouvernement ne prend pas les moyens
d'appliquer des lois qu'il a lui même
fait voter donc le gouvernement a une
responsabilité dans ce dysfonctionnement
quand une loi n'est pas appliquée et
quant à l'évidence l'application cette
loi aurait permis de protéger cette
femme
oui je crois que il faut se poser la
question de la responsabilité parce que
on ne peut pas continuer à laisser des
femmes mourir comme ça alors que les
plaintes ont été récurrentes chez cette
personne et qu'on sait qu'elle était en
danger de mort merci beaucoup laurence
garnier pour votre réaction après ce
temps fort des questions d'actualité au
sénat
merci beaucoup alexandre effectivement
c'était un moment de grande tension dans
l'hémicycle et qui pose la question du
décalage parfois entre la loi et son
application on va à nouveau rejoindre
alexandre poussard salle des conférences
sur un tout autre sujet vous êtes avec
la ministre déléguée à l'insertion ans
brigitte klinkert également tête de
liste pour les élections régionales dans
le grand test il ya beaucoup de choses à
dire sur les régionales aussi oui on
parle beaucoup des élections régionales
en ce moment notamment de la polémique
en région paca avec une alliance
possible entre les républicains et la
république en marche alors justement en
parlant des régions un grand test
brigitte klinkert puisque vous bonjour
puisque vous mener à une liste soutenue
par la majorité présidentielle
le rassemblement national dans cette
région est donné en tête au premier tour
est-ce que là aussi il faudrait dès le
premier tour une alliance entre les
républicains entre le président sortant
georges lautner
et votre liste déjà on ne peut pas
comparer la situation de la région grand
est avec la situation de paca les
chiffres sont différents
d'autre part j'ai un peu de mal à
comprendre pourquoi on veut toujours
pensé que c'est le rassemblement
national qui en tête vous savez avec la
candidature qui est la mienne je pensais
être vraiment avec mes colistiers le
meilleur antidote aux extrêmes et
notamment rassemblement national parce
que qu'est ce qui nourrit aujourd'hui
les extrêmes et le rassemblement
national c'est l'éloignement dans le
cadre notamment de la région grand est
où où il ya quand même eu une grande
centralisation de la gouvernance au sein
de cette région
donc l'éloignement le non respect des
identités voir le gommage des identités
de l'alsace de la lorraine et de la
champagne ardenne et la déconnexion des
habitants et des territoires et mon
projet mon projet elle justement un
grand changement
un choc de décentralisation de
rapprocher de nouveau les élus régionaux
des habitants et des territoires de nous
reconnecter avec les habitants et
surtout surtout le respect des identités
de chacun en alsace en lorraine et en
champagne-ardenne on a bien compris
votre projet un bon quand même sur les
sondages en ce moment les intentions de
vote si jamais au second tour il faut
faire barrage au rassemblement national
est ce que vous prendrez vos
responsabilités vous fusionnerait avec
un jean rottner
je prendrai mes responsabilités vous
savez je suis connu comme étant une
femme qui s'est rassemblée d'ailleurs la
liste que je conduis sera une liste de
grand rassemblement et d'union
je prendrai mes responsabilités merci
beaucoup aubry j'étais une carte d'avoir
répondu à ma question
merci merci beaucoup
[Musique]